[Music]
well cower and fear cowards that's right
baby we're back we're back we're back
[Applause]
wow they couldn't take us down Ethan
they tried they should have tried over
there guessing they tried to take us
down over the over this break I'll tuck
you up boy they can't do nothing about
it but they're gonna do it he's gone we
are all domestic terrorists
that's right
we have so much to talk about welcome
back Hassan 20 billion dollar complex
it's highly sophisticated and inflation
made it 30 billion now inflation shouts
out to Brandon ugh hate that guy
um how you been I've been you know how
yeah I was with you you were with me
yeah we had a good time over at your
house streaming yeah when you [ __ ] all
over my production and everything I do I
I was only literally hearing questions
that you asked me you literally were
like why are you covering your purse
like no one cares about what's going on
in your life I was like no they do
actually they want this there's no way
they care you're like they don't care
there's why are you watching a moist
critical video what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you yeah well you know what you've
invited me yeah I know you're a [ __ ]
menace I'm so I'm just happy that we
didn't get banned when you were there
holy [ __ ] I was so worried yeah he was
sweating bullets he would go to the back
I felt like Dan dude
thank you baby
brought him today because we were trying
to feed him yeah I heard I heard him uh
was was going on with that
boy
yeah anyway sorry
um he just he just started running at me
full speed so I had to acknowledge Him
yeah no no I understand
um
yeah you were you were uh [ __ ] all
over my operation yes yes yes and and
what I do for a living and you hated it
and it's fine I think well that's yeah I
mean we had a banger episode yeah on the
Pod it was great yeah it was good it was
fun I had a lot of fun over there I will
say every time Hassan went to the
bathroom I hopped in his chair and this
man came back like he's seen a ghost
like he was [ __ ] freaking when he saw
me in his chair every time bro I just I
just know I know what you are capable
I've seen what you've done okay and I
have no strikes the strike is gone our
channel is strikeless
so don't [ __ ] test me bro oh Jesus
he's like he's got what I mean he's like
I got I got one in the chamber right now
my dog is sick and I'm on the [ __ ]
Verge bro yeah you you uh actually I
might get banned for what I'm about to
say about George Santos today no shot
George Sanders is a legend I love him
well I agree to an extent but then when
I saw this story about how he basically
oh he killed Tony and the poor guys this
homeless vets dog yeah of cancer
[ __ ] I am that is the worst thing
he's done objectively like I am so
[ __ ] angry I was it's like it's
almost comical how bad okay we're
supposed that's a spoiler alert we're
gonna talk about that later we let's
let's we have so much to do we have so
much to cover that's crazy we have so
much to cover oh my God so um well
yeah let's see when you ask me what I do
for my break like or how my break was
like it's the same you know what I mean
my life my life does not change over the
break I just keep doing the same thing
let me see your hair you obviously cut
your hair you had a big old head of hair
now I personally I don't even think
that's a mullet to be honest with you
it's just like a it's a nice normal
haircut that's a little
it's just a little trimmed above that
you gotta you gotta take that up with my
main man uh friend of the show Jeff
that's who you got to take that up with
because are you unhappy with the haircut
no I'm happy with it I wanted to I
wanted to get a mullet in between before
I like go back to my regular like old
short hair basically and it's fine I
think like you know maybe the mall it's
not for me but uh the short hair
certainly is you know I just you grew
that hair out for so long just to get a
mullet I don't know man you you owe the
you owe the people better than that
I would not be talking about hairstyles
if I were you okay nobody's nobody's
making fun Hey listen like looking like
[ __ ] uh the Zoolander villain
people are saying I look like Bobby
that's true you do look like Bobby yeah
oh no that's the best one oh that's so
good yeah by the way so um apparently
Andrew Tate is live from prison right
now should we check that out I would
love to check that out I would no here
he is in detention I'm in prison he's is
this real but if you think about it it's
like a studio if you think about it
we're all in a prison we're trapped in
The Matrix
that's a good accent you did hit that
weird now that he's gone I I need to
steer these rudderless men uh you know
to the Bountiful
waves of misogyny when was the first
kiss okay okay
no no this has to be a a pre-record I
was kind of up and down I was working in
the fish market but I was still fighting
Vibes what is happening right now no
this is like you know what this is bro
he's like not much and then I this is
like one of those like crypto scams you
know like Elon Musk is talking about you
know selling Twitter and then it's like
a Bitcoin scam [ __ ] that like they
basically took over someone else's
account they hacked it and then they're
now doing this crypto scam because
there's no [ __ ] voice but there's
only 78 people watching that's the game
you put that seriously it's probably
just a loop of his own yeah it's a loop
of his old [ __ ] yeah yeah no this is not
what is this wait what did you read
Olivia he wasn't live yesterday
no they're just looping his old [ __ ]
probably there's no [ __ ] way he's the
corniest set I've ever seen
Vibes I heard something that is not
Vibes they'll be out of prison I mean he
he
I think he's gonna get out of uh
detainment soon I don't know it's like a
30 day hole they might extend it they
might also uh you know I don't know how
the Romanian court system works that
well but I suspect like if they consider
him to be a flight risk or a danger he
definitely is a flight uh they would
probably
extend his detention for the duration of
the trial bring me pizza
um
but yeah this this is from a month ago
Andrew yeah so okay Andrew enjoying your
PR I think he's gonna get detained I
think he's he's gonna stay in there
longer but okay whatever F and L
um
Trump is back on Twitter
uh he not yet he's I mean he's already
back like he's been unbanned right and
yeah Elon Musk like posted that tweet
about like please [ __ ] my ass Donald
Trump like if you remember that was like
very weird you remember that one I don't
remember him begging for that he no he
literally he posted a a tweet of like
like someone trying to get Jesus to have
sex with like this lady like showing her
butt to Jesus in the barn
to like get Jesus to [ __ ] her and then
and then he put like Twitter on the Elon
Musk oh yeah yeah yeah I'm not making no
no no no but you guys can find it I know
what you mean he's he's memeing him yeah
yeah you can't resist yeah yeah gotcha
gotcha please well he's come [ __ ] me
Elon I mean uh Trump that's what he did
uh it's gonna be so nice to have him
back it's gonna be so nice bro
yeah here's the meme you're talking
about hello
okay this this is pretty graphic Elon
I mean come on bro
I had a beat off
yeah that's what yeah I wasn't even I
wasn't even making that up I know it
sounds it sounds like I made it up
because it's so stupid and unhinged but
like I I wasn't
anyway so yeah he was like please please
Daddy did you hear this this news is
kind of crazy Alec Baldwin is being
charged with manslaughter
that's crazy that is so crazy here I did
not know that let's see the prosecutors
freaking news up in here leftovers oh
we're back what is It season three now
is it leftovers season three
you two could call at that I mean we
started yeah we started in 2021 [ __ ]
leftover season three that's crazy that
is crazy holy [ __ ] anyway yeah so we're
on season three and that's if we're
breaking news now
Alec Baldwin was charged you know he'd
been on like a whole defense tour
apparently I've been following it kind
of closely but the police have been
investigating him they've been asking
questions they've been interviewing him
I never thought they were actually going
to try to charge him though and this is
nuts I wonder what they've got on him
let's see
um
Baldwin says he did not pull the trigger
but it's been I think
proven or close to proven that he did
pull the trigger so what's up was there
a second shooter in the grassy no what's
he talking about
right but I mean it was an accident
right I mean he didn't I mean I don't
know I guess it's manslaughter it's
negligent homicide right
yeah yeah I heard on the radio on the
way in that he's being charged
specifically with um unintentional
manslaughter is what it's called in New
Mexico so unintentional manslaughter
right
that is wild that
like he could serve a criminal sentence
for this what's the crime for unintended
I mean yeah what's the sentence for
unintentional accidental
people
involuntary there you go involuntary
manslaughter that was the crime
that seems like such a convoluted uh
charge doesn't it yeah especially
because it's like New Mexico uh where I
feel like you could just like kill
someone deliberately and get away with
it right you know what I mean yeah
so I find that rather strange alfredo
um but you know other than that I mean
Hey listen if if
Alec Baldwin uh if there's new details
that are released and he was negligent
to the degree that like
he could have avoided shooting this
person and killing this person well the
problem was that he was like a producer
and Creator on the show like he was the
guy was his show yeah
by the way that's that's normal though
that's like pretty basic stuff that's
how most you know movies what happened
to what happened on the on the filming
of of the taping a crow
I believe that that was like was Brandon
Lee right that was that's right it's
randomly that was a total fluke right
where one of the blanks a shot of there
was stuck in the barrel yeah uh and then
the second blank like shot the uh
cartridge from the first blank out and
it killed him yeah that's crazy dude
I think they're I think they're stopping
to use blanks altogether on film set I
don't think they need them anymore just
go blanks just go for the special
effects yeah
a weird
part of me just like I love squibs
and I I even though they're very
dangerous and and like I understand why
people use blanks even though they are
also very dangerous like my advocacy
always revolves around like making sure
that you have
better workplace conditions when these
people are handling like super dangerous
material that is explosive ultimately
and to make sure that like they are well
taken care of and they're not getting uh
what the [ __ ] is squib bro what is this
squibs are like little explosive pellets
that
uh like Quentin Tarantino uses them
still oh it's for movie making yeah it's
for movie making we're like
they have basically stopped that all
together now they use like now they they
see they just they just CGI it it
doesn't look the same it doesn't no
scrubs are also like aggro so I guess
it's a little it's a little different
anyway whatever this is a total random
yeah just a headline I thought we were
breaking news season three yeah we're
like we are breaking news you know but
yeah Jeff uh you know hopefully I I
don't know if he's getting his surgery
now or if he's about to get a surgery
this week I hope he's uh doing all right
I hope he recovers so we can [ __ ] fix
my hair okay that's the only that's the
only reason why I'm surprised he's even
cutting hair with one good eye I mean
there's no way you cut your hair with
one good eye yeah would you see my hair
cut exactly that's what I'm saying the
Blind Barber he needs death perception
dude yeah I'm not trying to get Sweeney
todded or whatever he's just
one false slip of the scissor and you're
going down the trap door my friend love
the guy but you know I mean just quit
your day job yeah bro stick with the
beauty products okay
yeah thank you so do you want so here we
have a big ass story about this guy
George Santos who is probably
uh I don't even know it's just
we're not you know we're just giving the
my take dog ban we can talk about that I
was just going to set up and say do you
want to talk about this The Tick Tock
band yeah go for it uh I was banned on
Tick Tock which Philip DeFranco said was
a good thing by the way he did say that
we're battling we're duking it out is he
joking he was he just clipped it up I
don't appreciate him joking like it was
like someone clipped us out of context
and sent it to him so okay okay
um Phillip I mean he's on his he's on
his glow up Arc as well he's not he's
not he's my enemy as well as you you
guys are both on your Global because
we're losing weight I see no dude
he looks like he looks like he de-aged
and yeah he's like ROTC Cadet
yeah like he wears like dry fit and [ __ ]
now have you seen him I've saw the the
last video he did he had like this skin
tight like
he had this like skin tight under armor
shirt his pecs were like popping off a
little bit in it it's like I see what
you're doing Philly D That Sexy Phil
Right Sexy Phil I feel filled in
he had like two chains on yeah he looked
good
I don't know about this one I'm talking
about the one where I'm in the thumbbo I
you you avoided that one for some reason
I just went to the newest one wow he
does look skinny yeah I'll go click the
one that has you in it yeah is that how
does that make you feel that I'm in
another thumbnail let me see when's the
last one I appeared in
it's been a while well I only see one of
yours
well ah good damn it's been a while
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you're already in another one oh
no
wait hold on hold on
oh my God you're oh no dude Philly is he
actually trying to get back well we've
been afraid we've been on another one
we've been on break
you know what I mean wait a minute here
you see this is right where before we
went to break my fat ass and [ __ ] up
haircut from Jeff
thank you Philly all right whatever yeah
so anyway yeah he's looking good maybe
you should compliment him more so we'll
put you in a thumbnail
so what kind of bomb threats or [ __ ]
were you doing on Tick Tock to get you
you know the usual advocating for black
lives matter
is that on MLK Day is when Tick Tock
decided to strike the band Hammer but
the thing is
I mean the video is like kind of funny
it's not supposed to be like super
serious it's just like me reacting to a
cut video where I'm describing the
difference between like black lives
matter and all lives matter and why you
know one side of that argument is silly
and my editor Austin Knox decided to put
this next to one of those like sand
kinetic sand uh videos and also Subway
surfaces like a meta on Tick Tock right
now dude that's awesome and by the way
that [ __ ] was a banger apparently that
meta is very solid because this video
got in one hour got 700 000 views wait
love are you hearing this
it got 700 000 views where are you at
with the kinetic sand bro on the subway
surfer and whenever I go viral whenever
I go viral on Tick Tock immediately like
just like the the you know Tate Fanboys
and tater tots try to take your live
streams down yeah they Mass reported
they they're probably all you need is
probably like 100 to 200 people Max and
a bunch of different accounts to be able
to like masterpart someone and because
it's uh Tick Tock is run by just robots
I assume and not real human beings they
took my account down yet again for uh
well let's see what did you say and I'll
be the judge though okay you'll be the
judge black lives matter all lives
matter black lives matter I guess whole
lives matter like this is so awesome the
kinetic fan I I thought this was a joke
uh when I saw it on Twitter but this is
the actually the video he posted the
actual video yes you can see it on my
Tick Tock now it's been it's actually
kind of smart because you have these two
squares
you got to fill it up over here with
something yeah
there you go that's a great way to look
at the extremes on both sides one side
is saying black lives matter and you
know black lives are a part of all lives
so all lives clearly don't matter until
black lives matter because black lives
currently don't matter the other side is
saying now [ __ ] that all lies matter
actually I Can't Take My Eyes Off the
kinetic sand I'm being honest yeah the
subway is so sad everyone focused on
something different like me uh I look at
the subway surfers more than the kinetic
sand I think I'm more of a Subway
Surfers kind of guy same you know I'm
surprised they were even able to focus
on what you're saying enough to punish
you because they were not it doesn't
matter you could you could literally be
like hello my name is Hassan [ __ ] and I
like apples and if enough people Mass
report it take Taco Bell yeah [ __ ] this
guy well you got a manual review and
they said we reviewed it and we agree
with the manual I mean somebody typed it
to you think there's just Roblox no of
course it's AI you think about [ __ ]
AI bot responded to on chat Bots are
incredibly common that's usually what
they do either they Outsource it to like
Indonesia or they have chat Bots and now
they use chat Bots more frequently let
me show this okay
so here's the message you got
from Tick Tock support your account was
permanently banned due to multiple
Community violations so then I I it's
not on that thread there's a I did a
separate one oh it's not here yeah just
if you go to my profile you'll find it
but
look what what happened was uh they not
only came after me but they took down my
editor right they took down my editor's
account too what the [ __ ] did he do yeah
they banned my editor
my editor Austin Ox has his own Tick
Tock account with like 60 70 000
followers
and it's a hit job
well not by Tick Tock it's just by like
right wing groups they get together and
like try to take down all my fan
accounts and [ __ ] like that uh
deliberately
yeah I don't know if you posted it I got
it yeah so
basically what ended up happening there
was I I reached out Tick Tock support
because they were like oh Tick Tock
support will respond to you
and I told them like you know what
happened they checked it come back like
20 minutes later hi again Hassan after
speaking directly with our suspension
team the band will stay due to hateful
Behavior we apologize we could not give
you better news thank you for your
patience understanding you [ __ ]
racist like thank you for your patience
Mr racist man is what they said to me
pretty clever if it is a bot because
they got like the lowercase i a little
bit of typos in there
I think this is real bro and they're
just that it's just that crazy
I just don't think that a real human
being looked at that that's possible
that is possible or sometimes YouTube
has these policies that make no sense
where they're like no because you
because you offered the argument for all
lives matter that's it that's enough
like it doesn't matter that you're being
critical of it it's just you showed it
you're done I don't think there was that
much Nuance I think I am a firm believer
that they saw multiple people Mass
reporting it and then they just moved on
and and they just hit the band Hammer
it's happened multiple times now at this
point I've gotten permit uh once before
hold on I want to put some similar [ __ ]
I want to finish this kinetic sand video
matter too you're just [ __ ] wrong for
bringing that up the extreme in that
situation is one side saying correctly
that uh you know black people are
disproportionately targeted by the
criminal justice system and sometimes
even killed as a consequence of that
District you zoom on the sand part
I tried I can't do it anymore damn I'm
zoomed all the way I'll just okay guys
mute this wait hold on can I just mute
this and
no
so there that is
all right should we talk about the crowd
over Shapiro thing or just oh well we
got Bradley calling in at 11. okay we'll
do a quick ten we will do a quick tenor
on this Crowder versus Shapiro civil
Civil War unfolding in the right wing
circles it's so so good because oh
obviously Crowder and Ben are probably
the biggest conservative
uh Talking Heads yeah on YouTube yes
they are and um well the daily wire sent
Crowder
an offer to join their Network
and Crowder put out a video called big
con is in bed with big Tech
because he thought the offer was so
absurd so predatory he was insulted to
such a degree he had to go out
and expose it do I have that right yeah
[ __ ] stupid bro yeah
um he didn't say who it was but I think
everybody knew it was the daily wire
and then what's interesting
is that the daily res wire responded and
they're like we're so sorry about trying
to uh prey on you for your 50 million
dollars over four years
contract we offered you that you said
was slave labor
and Crowder's getting clowned on now
pretty much yeah at first everyone was
on his side even Jordan Peterson himself
actually did not know who Crowder was
talking about and like uh apparently
offered support to Crowder for his like
big con thing he now deleted that tweet
by the way wait and by the way because
Jordan Peterson is also under the daily
wire
umbrella as a as a podcaster
now
um all that stuff is great uh what is
psychotic to me is the number and at
first I thought maybe this is like a
marketing scheme to be like look how
look how much money the conservatives
have you know they're just like lying
about the contracts because like 50
million for a four-year contract is a
starting offer is bananas to me I do not
understand how they're generating that
level of Revenue but then I realize that
like it's not even about the stuff that
they're selling it's not like they're
you know woke racist razors or whatever
the [ __ ] it's just you know they're
funded by a lot of wealthy
uh billionaires millionaires that just
dump money into their propaganda Outlet
knowing full well the
uh knowing full well how valuable it is
to have someone [ __ ] saying these
racist things well compared to how much
money they waste on ads and [ __ ] this is
like the best return on investment ever
yeah with that lol
um there was a there was some really
funny parts of this contract but before
we even get into that one thing I do
want to mention is that
um you see a lot of people I will not be
naming them that start off on like uh
the left as content creators as baby
content creators and they can't cut it
on the left
and then they turn and they make a heel
turn to the right okay
and the crowd on the left you rarely
ever see the inverse of that Crowder did
not start on the left rarely ever see
the inverse of that usually because I I
am much more empathetic to people
understanding and changing their ways
and learning from their past mistakes
and becoming more open-minded more
Progressive because the amount of money
you can make if you want to be a
political commentator the amount of
money you can make with like
while simultaneously not being a very
entertaining figure uh is is almost
endless on the right you can make a lot
more money on the right grifting than
you can on the left okay because leftist
movements are not funded by you know
big Tech or uh whatever kind of Big
Industry in the same way that like
right-wing movements are
and it's all Grassroots and and you're
going to have to have an organic fan
base that uh loves you and believes what
you're you know believes in your content
enough to give you money
the right doesn't have these sorts of
problems
um so that's precisely the reason why
you see a lot more people grifting on
the right then you see it on the left I
absolutely despise when people are like
ah you're a left descriptor I'm like
dude if I wanted the grift I would just
become the best right wing broadcasts
are on the [ __ ] plan I think it would
be so fun to actually try that
like I have this fantasy of making an
anonymous right wing
YouTube channel I've thought about that
hiding my face right
that'd be awesome yeah and then being
like psych you fox wait till daily wire
gives you a contract
here's here's Crowder crying about his
50 million dollar over four-year
contract
big Tech is in bed with big con
by the way he's so [ __ ] angry that
Ben Shapiro wanted to give him 50
million dollars what a [ __ ] [ __ ] as
a starting offer they like it was going
to get higher than that also and he's so
angry that he's willing to go public
with it this it's just it's not
happening Ben
how dare you insult me it's starting at
50 million I wonder if his Gremlins know
how much money he makes
pot
the people I thought fight like hell for
50 million dollars
that's just like it's so funny these
guys Their audience is constantly coming
to my chat to be like you're [ __ ]
commie grifter you make so much money
you're so rich you're so rich I'm like
brother
I make money because people voluntarily
give me five dollars a [ __ ] month
yeah when all of my content is famously
free okay not only is it free that not
only is it so free that you can watch it
on YouTube if you want
you can watch it on Twitch there's no
like paywalls in that regard
um but also on top of that you could
literally take the content yourself
re-upload it and make money yourself
that's why I have thousands of [ __ ]
channels on YouTube that are fan Channel
okay
and yet people still choose to give five
dollars a month and [ __ ] are
mad at me for that
meanwhile this guy is complaining about
50 million dollars over the course of
four years that's crazy this is the best
expose on him because his fans are
really getting a glimpse into like how
not working class these guys are you
know look at Jordan Peterson he goes
Stephen Crowder on the hypocrisy of
conservative Legacy Media Jordan
Peterson who these days you can pretty
much always count on the dumbest take on
any given situation talking about the
organization that he's a part of
and then erasing it a fact what a
[ __ ] idiot hell yeah precisely
so the other the other part of this
though I have to call you out for a
second because I said [ __ ] did I do I
said on my YouTube page on my own
personal YouTube page I get 25 million
views a month but at the hospital
industrial complex the clips complex the
universe gets around 55 to 60 million
views a month on top of that mm-hmm
that's 85 million views a month
right I got it you said Stephen Crowder
has more of a YouTube presence than me
no that's first of all I didn't say that
I said you guys are about the same
that's crazy I just looked it up he's
crowded first of all first of all this
65 Million number you're pulling out of
your thin air I need some backing
evidence for that okay just the 20 XL I
need to excel just a 25 million alone uh
still destroys Stephen Crowder I didn't
know that Crowder bits gets one million
views uh a month Stephen Carter's main
channel gets around 12 million 13
million views a month I'm almost
doubling up on my just a channel bro
damn I said well Hassan was trying to he
goes he starts flexing he goes yo 50
million I'm more way more relevant than
he is and well first of all as you just
I said well you're about as relevant I'd
say because he he is big I think now now
before I'll say this I went to his
channel he didn't have any as many views
as I remember so I'm thinking you should
take that deal Crowder because it seems
like you're on the downswing but
hasanabe is super relevant and um he's
looking to join the daily wire as well
give me the 50 million I will be I will
be the attractive Stephen Crowder I'm
just going to start being
mad Chad is saying you do look like
Steven Crowder right now with the
haircut that is such disrespectful
slander I will be suing all of you
yeah but um you'll be hearing from my
lawyer the daily wire team you'll be
here for my Laura Ben Shapiro he went to
Harvard you would take 50 million you
broke loser even Steven Crowder will
settle for that of course I would not
100 million it's like that's the no no
there is I've talked about this so many
times but like you know people won't
believe me but like I already make too
much [ __ ] money there is no amount of
money that would get me to like
change my principles because like why
the [ __ ] would I I already make what I
already have my own uh I already make
enough money with my own advocacy 50
million I'll say whatever you want
you're crazy I'll be whoever you want
you're such a lot I'll be like yo trans
people are lame you're worse
dude how much money you make now the
difference between how much revenue you
generate right now versus how much more
money you would make
insignificant in the closet I just got a
50 million dollars the point is it's
insignificant because like hormone
replacement therapy is child grooming
okay you're gonna get 50 million you're
gonna get banned because like check
right you're gonna get oh stop it smell
it tastes good on my lips I love it what
a [ __ ] Weasley Little Liar my point
is my point is the difference is how
much money I make Now versus like that
level of money is not going to improve
my quality of life so dramatically it's
not gonna change my life
cause you ain't making 50 million no
because what the [ __ ] am I going to do
with 50 million say that now sit when
people ask me what do you like to do I'm
like I literally do what I like to do I
sit at my [ __ ] room and I yell for
eight hours you sound broke
just saying all right here let's watch
let's watch Crowder uh talk about the
big con
we're fighting for you
a lot of it has been
a big con now they're not fighting for
you they only offered me 50 million
dollars yeah it's all a big con waiting
naming names or going after individuals
in this video
because I genuinely hope that those I'm
addressing and you know who you are have
a change of heart don't sign don't sign
these contracts
who are you talking to like who else is
getting 50 million contracts out there
hey guys don't sign these
I know I now know what you are signing
out there I have the luxury of not
having to you know let me go through
this if any of the major platforms
issues a Content strike such that
Crowder cannot be monetized on such
platform the fee will be reduced by 25
that's not that much by the way if
they're like yo you're permanently
banned from YouTube for whatever reason
we're just gonna cut it by 25 like I
thought you would ride for him on this
one because you know you're Mr [ __ ]
Dan happy well listen at a certain
degree
if you're signing a contract to provide
content for somebody and you literally
can I mean getting 75 percent of your of
your salary is still pretty dope
another 20 of it happens on Apple and
then another 10 of happens on Facebook
and then another 10 of it happens on
Spotify and then if you're gonna
probably just don't do mock executions
of Jordan Floyd bro if you're so I mean
come on bro it's so funny he has a
racism claw that his contract he's like
oh I have my lawyers on this I should be
able to say the n-word okay I put it in
the contract I have to say it it's
literally a fundamental part of my
content I have to be the biggest most
racist goober you've ever seen the
n-word
yeah that he would be he would become no
but that's it no that's literally it
he's like I need to be able to get
banned because that's the kind of
content I put out there I mean I even
see his side of this argument almost
because like you're hiring him yeah to
be a racist yeah so a part of that is
also getting banned yeah okay every now
and then I think there's talking about
like permanently banned right like if
you're gonna go bye-bye hold on hold on
then if you get a strike
meaning a suspension oh another 20 just
to drive it home you get hit by a car
you have a sick day you can two thousand
dollars a day this is what's sent out to
every damn that sucks bro everyone's
feeling super bad for you right now I'm
gonna stop dissing the Nazis all the
time here's the cut out I give the part
he really uh let's see reduction of fees
lost from boycott content strikes or
bans for major media yeah I guess
because their whole thing is like yo
weird these people are corrupt and they
make they ban you for no reason and then
on the back end they're like yeah and so
anyway if they do ban you they're right
and we're gonna dock your pay
yeah
which is what YouTube does that's like
90 of his content is like screaming
about YouTube Banning him for like doing
blackface every week you know what I
mean and then right and then now he's
going to get a contract with [ __ ]
daily wire and daily wire's like hey we
love your black face contest so good
also if your blackface content gets you
banned so you're not gonna make money
can you pull up the like dislike on this
Dan I want to see
I want to see if he's getting owned
oh no his fans are riding no his fans
were riding for him until uh the daily
wire came out and was like yeah Stephen
Crowder uh is like lying about the
contract then it's like 50 million as a
starting offer
yeah it's possible too that like
there's gotta be like a
an exit amount where it's like yes if
you get banned you lose this amount but
if we cancel the contract you'll get
this amount if I don't know he's a loser
I just I can't get over the fact that a
four year contract
for Stephen Crowder dude that's like top
athlete money is no 50 million is 12
million 12.5 million a year I think
right isn't it is that not top athlete
money no really they make a lot more
than that I think top athletes make a
lot more than 12 million yeah not top
but I would say like but like mid tier I
got mid uh upper mid tier yeah mid-tier
to Upper mid tier depending on what
industry we're talking about too
depending on what sport we're talking
about obviously but like but even then
it's it's a lot of [ __ ] cookies right
like it's a lot of money and
it blows my mind that like
the daily wire could burn 12.5 million a
year on Stephen Crowder it is and it did
they must be doing insane numbers dude
they're not they just have date one
thing that I I they have a funding no
rich people they just you say here's
hundreds of millions of dollars
yes they do that
Ethan what the [ __ ] do you think prageru
is Prager University okay it's not a
real University it has no way of
generating Revenue it is entirely funded
by Oil Barons adult Interest Who
basically who a hundred million dollars
is nothing to them you know what I mean
they just burn it why do they do it and
this one is for all the [ __ ] sweaty
crusty showerless anarchists out there
on Twitter who don't [ __ ] understand
the fundamental role that propaganda
plays those guys get it they know that
propaganda is invaluable they know and
they'll pay for it all right so this
apparently is the guys who fund the
daily wire brother and sister want to
make love for the con for the beautiful
content the dentist
this this is the how do you know this is
him Dan and Ferris Wilkes
yeah
sounds like the dude who killed Lincoln
coincidence they have like these guys
have some insane [ __ ] in their
background too by the way that's not
even like they are I mean they're very
funny looking which is great
oh they are that's awesome yeah [ __ ]
idiots
they're sons of a bricklayer actually
they gave uh Mason 15 million to a Super
PAC supporting Cruise waste of money
they gave 50 000 I mean who cares it's
nothing they gave 75 000. so where's the
evidence that they're giving a gajillion
dollars to daily wire
these are the guys that found the daily
wire I don't know if it's in the
Wikipedia uh oh oh oh sorry these are
the guns that wait aren't these also the
guys that [ __ ] fund uh prageru or
maybe it's not money so if these guys
pull the plug those webs you think
Prager and daily wire just go away one
million there is no world in which the
daily wire is able to self-fund the
media is media is an incredibly
expensive Endeavor yeah especially when
you do not have like especially when you
have a large crew
and you're buying other content creators
to like bring them under your own
umbrella
um Ben Shapiro is incredibly popular
he's got one of the most
successful podcasts in the world I agree
I understand YouTube channel is huge but
like yeah I mean if he and we're talking
about generating Revenue 50 million is
probably how much he's generating from
that
so how's it going to give up you think
Ben Shapiro is generating 50 million
dollars in Revenue a year yeah you think
I'm overestimating
so maybe maybe you're right
dude the podcast alone because it's
super popular gets more views than ours
downloads and [ __ ] and you're not I'm
not even thinking about Facebook I'm
sure he kills there dude daily wire is
one of the most popular Facebook pages
too that's true daily wire daily wire in
and of itself makes a lot of money they
generate 50 million a year actually
considering the face they have a whole
paywall like premium content thing too
the daily wire plus 100 million I think
they make 100 million I think the daily
wire generates a hundred million dollars
in Revenue a year so and that's that's
just straight up them earning that's not
anyone giving them money what'd you say
B
I said the daily wire themselves say
they make 100 million a year that I
believe I think that's accurate okay
because the Facebook views the podcast
popularity I can't imagine that any of
these other goons are doing much work
for them well Jordan Peterson now is is
obviously huge although I can't imagine
how much they're paying that [ __ ]
idiot in month 14 the company became
cash flow positive and has driven
exponential growth with no additional
outside capitals what they're saying
they started off with small initial
investment by these two guys uh to the
tune of 4.77 uh to the point of four ah
I can't talk 4.7 million in 2015 as well
I hate to break it teal
but I think they actually make them I
don't think they're running off oil
money maybe they started but I think
Benny boy is in there getting checks
there is no I just can't see that man I
can't see that because like the NRA
didn't fall apart because they got under
like legal scrutiny they fell apart
because they tried to do TV like media
is is either incredibly profitable and
very valuable and he's self-made but
these NRA goons don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing I agree but these kinds of
like uh uh I'm sorry bro
we are trying to expand their operation
to Encompass Stephen Crowder as well
they bought out Jordan Peterson uh
Candace Owens like all these people I
just cannot see this being a sustainable
Enterprise knowing what I know about the
media especially when the funding
vehicle for the media is advertisement
revenue and they are constantly they're
constantly under hot water with adrev
because uh advertisers boycott their
stuff they get banned off platforms they
might have been able to create a
self-sustaining mechanism but it just I
don't know maybe it's just like a a
scary
thought uh that that like these Outlets
are generating this level of Revenue but
just like what I said
just like what I said earlier I think we
over emphasize and and uh overestimate
the amount of people that watch these
people
and it's the same with the revenue that
they generate as well I think it's
overestimated
I don't think they may go home
crazy bro they do I'm sorry bro I'm
sorry like Facebook is a couple million
YouTube is like maximum 10 to 15 million
no you
there's no way based on what I
understand of the business that I'm in
what is Ben Shapiro's Adventure as a
main channel right
he's getting 62 million okay Ben Ben is
making a lot of money he makes 62
million video views uh a month
ugh I hate to break it to you bro but
this this is real this is not being
funded I really I'm sorry guys you gotta
just accept it the people they love
fascism right now they love this [ __ ]
they hate the gays and they love the
fasces and it's hot top dollar right now
it is Tim Poole's out there making bank
doesn't have a coherent thought a lot of
these people surely uh they get they get
paid there's enough there's enough of an
audience out there but I don't think uh
I think that there's a lot more shadowy
funding happening behind the scenes than
you would expect where's my George Soros
mommy bro I'm waiting for that check
like that's projection that's pure
projection [ __ ] is the George Soros
dollars dude
can I just chime in I think it's
probably a combination of both I think
they make a [ __ ] ton of money but I
think they also probably get subsidized
and the reason I think that is because
their whole premium service hold on I
should switch to myself sorry I'm
switching today people
um their whole premium service
um
they have like a whole back-end
infrastructure for that like that that's
not on
YouTube or Vimeo or something they have
their own video streaming platform and
that [ __ ] is super expensive it's not
that bad they have the money it's like
their own proprietary they're not
hosting like terabytes of [ __ ]
content they are I mean they have like
well it's there if it's their own
content people are paying for it then
it's just a matter of money which they
have yeah I'm waiting for Ben Shapiro
only fans that's when the real money's
coming
by the way so Tim Poole who I just
mentioned he's thinking this [ __ ]
idiot who the [ __ ] is putting this on no
that's just this this right here is
literally
who in my opinion indicative of temples
like lack of clout okay you don't do
this if you have an organic audience
this is the biggest waste of money I can
ever imagine no it's not here's why I
mean it is a waste of money if you want
eyeballs it's not a waste of money if
you want people to think you are a
legitimate Enterprise really I'm gonna
look at this and think this is
legitimate yeah
he looks he's holding a [ __ ] like
standard podcast it doesn't matter it's
on Time Square people look at that and
go oh that's like this looks like spam
this absolutely
this is not I don't know it's just I
think it's kind of embarrassing
look at this [ __ ] this is for this is
for advertisers and other uh Brands and
and people let's get out let's go put
let's put an ad out for leftovers we
could easily do that it's like someone
said it's like 12 Grand or something in
the Twitter thread or Temple yeah it's
nothing 12 grand for the month can we
get Ethan no it's got to be more than
that no it's nothing bro Billboards what
the [ __ ] do you mean no I I've looked
into billboard advertising for Teddy
fresh and like in a dumb [ __ ] stupid
neighborhood it's like in L.A yeah uh
next to nothing though like it's just
that's a single it depends on uh flow of
traffic uh but here on Times Square this
is like overcast uh next to like
thousands of other advertisers
this is Times Square a billboard
converging costs from
five thousand for a one day program to
well over fifty thousand typically the
minimum amount of money required to
advertise for a short amount of time one
to three days is between five to three
you said it was Twelve Grand
he's at 12th that who claims the ads
cost 12.5 K per month though it's
unclear if that's for one ad or for all
three they don't seem to be attracting
any interest though I know for a fact uh
on Sunset Boulevard uh if you want a
month billboard it's like over 100 grand
yo we need to pull one out just next to
him that's like this guy's an idiot
maybe it's because it's like a tiny one
it's not on like the mid yeah it's got a
Jumbotron or something it's got to be
that Off-Broadway [ __ ] Dollar Store
[ __ ] he just wanted the phone yeah if it
is 12.5 K is is cheap for a month for
sure for an ad of this size because you
just get one day and then you get the
photo and then because nobody actually
looks at it and cares like we just buy
one day's worth of us being like this
guy's a [ __ ] idiot
by the way these guys are inbred
their parents [ __ ] and they're the
result of that I told you they look
weird straight up two siblings produce
these [ __ ] guys guaranteed
you know what I mean it's Straight
siblings adult interest there it is like
to this day no one knows who funds the
Federalist okay
Federalist is like a legacy newspaper
for the right what's that right-wing
newspaper yeah nobody knows who funds it
a lot of these they there is not enough
eyeballs on this [ __ ] thing for it to
be a self-sustaining Enterprise it is
basically just make work for uh spoiled
inbred Republicans that went to Yale and
couldn't cut it in like any other viable
industry and they want to write articles
about how like you know [ __ ] Hypno porn
should be banned because it's making me
gay you know what I mean like that's
literally what the Federalist is about
that's what so many of these operations
are about they're not actually like in
it for the real eyeballs as long as they
can sustain as long as they can get just
like Turning Point USA as long as they
can make the old [ __ ] feel like they're
actually reaching out to the youth then
uh the old folks will keep funding it
George Soros can we reach out does he
have an email address will you accept
money from George Soros he's just keep
being you know he's a communist Hassan
why wouldn't you accept no no no no
dude he just is like just keep being you
no strings attached I probably still
would not take it you're just like a
million dollars because it's just the
the [ __ ] credibility hit would be
yeah someone would assassinate you for
sure if you took money from yeah I don't
want to say it but he's like yell Hassan
just be yourself bro no strings attached
here's a hundred million dollars
no
I don't need it because there's no such
thing there's no such thing as a free
lunch there's no such thing as a hundred
million dollars with no strings attached
okay okay it's not happening
um is Bradley on the line what's going
on there he is not in the zoom waiting
room yet did he stand us up I'm gonna
text him right now yeah tell him yo bro
this is live we're waiting for you man
don't they say don't stand us up like
Steve will do it to you you know how
that feels don't do it to us it's a Vibe
right now
should I call him
yeah but but just tell him he's live
before you put it on the yeah
um oh he said he's calling now okay good
so my goal here is to
we know he's kind of susceptive to the
Andrew Tate
I saw a video that I don't have access
to the link you guys posted by the way
Dan
um I saw a video on Monday that like
blew my mind and you've probably seen it
oh yeah you did it was the lawyer
reacting to that like leaked Hustler
University video yeah
and you know this video is extremely
hard to find the only place I found it
and we've looked everywhere is this
lawyer talking about I've I've watched
it Bradley's in the uh waiting room no I
know you've yeah I know you've watched
it but I can't find the video anywhere
oh because it's uh they I think his team
probably copy strikes those because they
are paywalled content technically right
well yeah well right if you re-upload it
yeah there he is you guys see me yeah I
can see you bro what's up yo first off I
gotta say I love the new haircut bro
thank you man are you talking about you
is he talking to me or are you talking
to you thank you bro thanks bro
appreciate that no no no what you guys
what are you guys doing what's going on
right now all right Bradley
I want to try I want I need to get your
opinion on something I know you're
open-minded clenbuterol how quickly can
we get Ethan on it no definitely don't
do it
no Clan is is such a bad thing you don't
want to do it which one no oral steroids
Clan is the horse bronchitis medication
yeah it's just it's just it's too acute
like you know it's just too much too
fast I wouldn't do that are you driving
right now Bradley no I would never drive
and be honest
this is Primal as [ __ ] dude you're like
looking down you're not even looking at
the road bro look at this [ __ ] oh Jesus
to the gym right now I'm all right all
right congrats on the news bro it
doesn't matter you could just [ __ ]
drive over people you wouldn't even know
about it yeah he wouldn't feel it yeah
you just walk out like unbreakable yeah
la la infrastructure baby what people
are for sure mad at me right now that
I'm driving on this call I know yeah
just don't okay I'm pulling in but go
ahead you're Alpha you're Alpha don't
you don't concern yourself with what
[ __ ] sheep think okay you're a lion
all right here here's what I want to I
want to first of all say
lots of love in our fans uh for you for
what you did on that milk podcast you
try to bring the truth to them did you
see it us appreciating that
yeah I did I did I saw them talking
about and honestly man like I
it's just I don't know when you it's
like when you bring up anything that's
opposing obviously everyone's like yo
what the [ __ ] we didn't really go into
it I mean I don't even know enough about
the whole thing to really go into it but
I just remember having that conversation
with you then I did some research and
the word for word likeness on the
website was like
was what I was looking up oh yeah lover
boys yeah yeah so yeah so well here here
I I want to show you a video
okay are we gonna get him to watch the
video he we can show him a video right
Dan yeah it's gonna show up on your
phone show him a video can we wait until
he's parked no I want you hey I'm gonna
park right now I gotta tell you guys
your guy's a setup is so legit yeah like
I know I said a few times but I'm like
really impressed man yeah anyways
the more you talk about it the better I
feel about it I love that no dude
honestly like you make me feel like I'm
just getting started and I I really have
some work to do Bradley just put the
phone in your lap and just look straight
down at the video
yeah perfect perfect yeah you ready I'm
Gonna Roll around oh I feel like I'm
your dick bro yeah
bro I'm gonna [ __ ] Park okay yeah and
congrats on the gym sorry that Steve
will do it betrayed you once again what
happened yeah
he didn't show up man that kind of hurt
my feelings am I gonna lie I was upset
actually upset because like all jokes
and [ __ ] aside
you know it did make me feel the type of
way for sure and and did you guys work
it out
yeah yeah he's gonna come he said sorry
he did and so I have to tell you
something you tweeted out that uh
you lied Steve will do it did jerk off
yourself
oh no and then you quickly you quickly
erased it what happened there well
because I was just like uh it's not
really I was just I was mad and I was
joked yeah we heard why'd you erase it
though you think it was because like
when you named it Zoo culture Steve will
do a thought like there will be animals
to jerk off there and that's why he was
excited and then he was like oh [ __ ]
there's no animals that jerk off here
I'm not coming that is interesting no
but yeah I did I wasn't posting delete
because I was like yeah it's not worth
it oh that was so funny come on I might
I should have left it it was it was
pretty good I'm the cool dad now well I
was gonna I was gonna call tweet it and
say 90 bro 90 of the poll yeah
[ __ ] the H3 audience poll never lies
all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah wait Steve will do
wait hold on what is this breaking news
oh yeah here's the thing yeah yeah we
can hear you yeah okay good I mean you
heard it here bro like you were angry so
how am I supposed to know that this
wasn't you being truthful no because I
was I'll tell you why because I was
sitting at lunch and I was like should I
just do it and I was talking to my boys
like the guys who helped me make content
it's so funny seeing that tweet and then
I was like I like con I contemplated it
and I posted and then I was like ah is
that kind of [ __ ] up because I didn't
want to be mean because it's not true
actually are you sure because again
because I'm just putting myself in your
in your shoes if I'm angry and I'm
trying to exact Revenge then I'm gonna
be like this thing I said isn't true is
true because it did happen no see
because I just tried to I try to pull
like a Steve will do it which was just
like make random [ __ ] up about someone
for like drama and like [ __ ] like
like I was a drug dealer I never
actually sold drugs but it was a
hilarious joke for time and then I was
like yeah that's not really what I do so
I took it back you know okay so so he
did not jerk off his dog
remember you did that poll and that was
pretty damn yeah yeah all right here I
want so my here's why I want you here
I want to show you a video
of Andrew Tate
okay I want you to just watch this video
and then I want you to tell me what you
think about it it's a new video I just
saw it for the first it's not a new
video it's an old video of his from the
website of the package that he was
selling yeah I mean what I mean by new
is I just saw it for the first time on
Monday so this is even kind of newly
Unearthed clip and it's from Hustler
University so this is what he's people
are paying him to teach uh young men how
to how to find their way in the world so
make sure you're in a comfortable place
here I'm gonna open this up for you
this was very hard to come by by the way
um I've never seen any of this [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah so it's two minutes it's two
minutes and 40 seconds and we edited it
uh together
for you or is it right no so no no they
took it off it's real so okay I've seen
this video in its original form and it
was re-uploaded to YouTube many many
times over but because it's paywalled
content they oftentimes like dmca strike
it you know what I mean because it's
like it's one of his like how to start a
webcam business you know how the website
that you read from like the old website
before he like deleted it after people
yelled at him and said like this is sex
trafficking this basically was the
accompanying video like Tai Lopez Style
video uh educational web seminar that he
he sold
but do you have a car in the back and he
was like but look at all these books he
doesn't do that he said look at all
these [ __ ] he does do that a little
bit yeah all right you ready dude you
strap in man strapping strap in just
watch this and I want your on a steak
here it is you're saying things like
oh yeah but you're always working I have
to do some traveling and you can't come
I want to bring you with me traveling is
a great one because the thing is about
this business is mobile if you can find
a good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else can you hear it
okay do you have earbuds you're trying
to [ __ ] yeah we put earphones on yeah
yeah yeah as beautiful as your ear is to
stare at bro
please work dude yeah yeah this video
rules man yeah I think you're gonna love
it
are you ready
hold on hold on okay okay yeah it's
worth I don't know if these are
these oh I think the only pair that has
no power bro hold on no it's all good
it's all good tell me when you're ready
I'll just chat with Hassan
are you excited you think this is gonna
be oh [ __ ] dick Vision again I love I
love this angle he doesn't think we're
watching but we I love Brad he's he's a
good guy
yeah I actually like this this is candid
this is cool bro you and I have to go to
his gym I'd love to one Sunday we're
just straight up going to his gym it
sounds dope his new gym and we're
working out there okay I'm into it okay
yeah and then I'm gonna secretly put
steroids in your food hell yeah well now
oral steroids are really bad for you yo
Ethan drink this no we'll do we'll do
I'll
jab you and I'll tell you it's the
vaccine because you know you're a
liberal so you love that thanks bro be
like yeah give me more of the vaccine
please and the vaccine is anabolic
steroids Brad you good
we we love Brad
I'm getting my mom Vibes yeah yeah all
right he's nice he took that he took the
air what happened he took the pause out
yeah they were working they were
connected so I'm gonna go in this room
right here okay he's cool night the the
roof looks great by the way
oh yeah okay
hold on how do I spin this around okay
real quick
yeah I know it's lit God damn [ __ ] bro
how do you fiddle of [ __ ] all those
people in there I mean dude it's it it's
giving me like real New Jersey gym Vibes
in a good way though not in a bad way
yeah okay I'm ready all right all right
cool all right here we go this is good
this is worth it you're gonna love this
here we go then you start saying things
like
oh yeah but you're always working I have
to do some traveling and you can't come
I want to bring you with me traveling is
a great one because the thing is about
this business is mobile if you can find
a good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little caveat to throw in oh and you're
all always working why don't you work
for me so we spend more time together
we're a few doing well so we'll have a
webcam business oh I don't want to do
that so okay I know you don't want to do
that but listen come let's have a
meeting let's just talk about it we
don't want to do it don't do it fine but
let me explain it to you properly in
fact I'll bring one of the girls who
works for me
you your Bolton [ __ ] the new girl you
go out for [ __ ] a nice dinner your
Bolton [ __ ] is the one who does the
selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where you're going back as well that's
why I said it's so important to have a
good first girl tax is also another
important element for controlling your
woman
you're not going to pay anybody tax
because you're getting paid in Bitcoin
so you don't need to pay tax to anybody
you tell your girl
that you're paying the tax
because girls are lazy and girls are
stupid and girls don't understand how
taxes work
so the girls working with you and you're
like oh okay yeah we've made this much
money but I'm going to pay the tax to
make sure we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay
now that allows you to do two things one
is another control element I work with
him my tax is not a problem if I do it
alone I have to deal with taxes taxes
are complicated so control element it
allows you to pay her a smaller
percentage
so I used to pay my girls 13 percent
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes so you're on fifty
percent and you have to pay the tax
first and then it's 50 50. if they say
why is it 50 50 because I'm the one on
camera you say because I'm the one
typing I'm the one with the the property
you're working in I'm the one paying the
bills the electricity I'm the one who's
uh and the electricity and every other
maintenance cost of this property I'm
the one who bought the equipment I'm the
one who knows what he's doing I'm the
one with the knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that if they respect you as a person
overall so really you're paying 30 you
tell them you're paying 50. the
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
if you if they don't believe you or they
want to get fresh or whatever print out
some tax forms I see this all the time I
used to print out some random tax forms
so yeah sign here and sign this what is
it it's for the tax you want to pay the
tax or not
okay and they just signed away they're
not [ __ ] signing let's throw them
away afterwards but they think
something's happening something real is
happening nothing's happening it's like
me different HP oh is that it
so I just want to summarize
so
um part one is he's the the part one is
the the most like uh the the most
serious one which is like I've said this
before but like he did do the same thing
like low budget Jeffrey Epstein thing
basically where Jeffrey Epstein had
Glenn Maxwell and he would use Glenn
Maxwell to like coerce the women into
sex trafficking
um and he's basically doing the same
thing he's like you need to have your
first like loyal uh bottom [ __ ] I guess
is I'm like you come with you to like
tell these women like look how look how
easy it is look how great it is like
that that creates a sense of security
um and then uh and then you just lie to
them well you lie to them you you
garnish their wages and you pay them uh
significantly less than what you're
actually telling uh what they're
actually making you lie to them and say
that you're paying their taxes when
you're not that's fraud by the way yeah
all of that is fraudulent yeah and also
printing out go ahead oh yeah go ahead
Brad I can't wait this is what I find
really interesting listen go ahead
obviously
speak your heart these people these
girls who are willingly doing this to
make money right we have to we have to
show that they did not want to do this
in order for it to be considered sex
trafficking or no
um so because at some point a girl who's
like
God has a plan
to be based on this clip he's a very
shrew
to people that I've ever done business
with are so do you think well hold on
let me ask you this do you think being a
shrewd business person is stealing 20
from your employee and lying to them and
they're printing out fraudulent tax
forms
so so they're obviously there are issues
with this for sure but my question
ultimately goes yeah does that person
regardless of that is just being forced
to do this or is she willing to do this
right now the other thing that I just
want to point out before we go further
in this
um
and and this has nothing really to do
with the actual Stitch against Andrew
Tate the trafficking stuff for the
accusations but the fact that we're also
talking about another person who has
been like I don't know if they're
they're
relinquished of these issues or this is
this Maxwell chick if she's just walking
around on Earth feeling but like I hope
the thing that gets me about all this is
that Angie takes such a big figure and
such a such a massive character that
like it's really fun to make content and
all the stuff around him because it gets
it's viral and it goes people get views
but how come we don't have the same
energy towards people we know that are
on some [ __ ] list somewhere that we
never get to know about who why don't we
go towards that who why don't we
clickbait every [ __ ] title about it
who are you talking about
I'm just talking about the fact that
we're sitting here discussing this Angie
taste thing which I understand can be an
issue and is an issue right now right
but he's fun to make content about yeah
at the same time we're talking about
someone Maxwell who's still alive
well she did go to jail she's in jail
bro but but I mean you're you're talking
to someone who has made a lot of content
about Gillian Maxwell and Jeffrey
Epstein uh but I I still make a lot of
content about Jeffrey Epstein England
Maxwell I talk about this sort of stuff
all the time we've talked about it on
leftovers too I mind gobbed by this
point what why should I talk more about
G Lane Maxwell
I'm talking about why do we know more
about the people who are on that list
well I'm sure
the clients of Jeffrey Epstein and Glenn
Maxwell unfortunately uh were were are
probably never going to be uh unsealed
that's just their that's my thing right
that's the thing look I understand no I
get that
but it's like we're making all this
because of the [ __ ] truthfully that I
believe no that's not true that's not
true I I'm telling you I make plenty of
content about Gillian Maxwell I made
plenty of content about going Maxwell as
well not just that it's the rest of the
world the rest of the world let me let
me explain uh from my perspective
uh you first of all you can care about
two things at once right 100 okay okay
so so we acknowledge that so and then at
the same time Andrew Tate's influence is
as big as people talk about him
so okay so that that my opinion explains
why people talk about them so much
because there's so many people that
still support him and to go back to the
video here's him saying now consent now
outwardly getting someone's consent
uh there's like if you look at like what
Jeffrey Epstein was charged for you
could make the same argument like the
girls came by their own free will they
said hey come do a massage we're going
to pay you money and then he ended up
being like hey you got to jerk me off
now they could have left they didn't
force them to stay it's coercion right
it's false pretense so if Andrew Tate is
innocent then so is Jeffrey Epstein you
understand that point like because I'm
pretty familiar with the crimes of
Epstein and what went down in these
massages he sent G Lane to recruit girls
he used other girls to recruit girls
they come in they start giving them a
massage and then he'd flip over and take
his dick out and like horrify them and
see if they jerk them off like legit
that was his Mo and so you could you
could what yeah so you could easily say
well they they could have left they
could have left I mean a lot of them
were underage so that's a different
point but you could say they could have
left now listen I'll I'll respond to
that
now we're talking about a woman who's
making a lot of money versus making no
money not just jerky coming off on a
massage
what
now we're talking about we're talking
about from what I understand Tay just
talking about
is getting a woman yes he's making a lot
of money off of her and leveraging her
she's also making a lot of money you're
relating that to someone jerking someone
I don't know how much money she's making
no I don't know here's the here's the
here's the other side of that a lot of
what will I Believe come out from this
investigation is uh what is similar to
what happened with Nexium
I don't know if I'm saying it correctly
Nexium which is a uh which was also
built around a cult of personality uh
who is now an imprisoned racketeer and
sex offender Keith Rainier now that guy
also did like motivational videos or
like motivational seminars and then he
basically built a sex cult uh uh on top
of that on the side
and he would do the same thing he had
like a bottom [ __ ] and then he would go
and like find other women and like bring
them in he even had some famous
celebrities uh involved in his cult as
well and and it is identical where you
you get these women to basically leave
everything behind sometimes come to a
different area a different location like
Romania right you take him out of
Moldova you take him out of like the
United States take them out of the UK
and you fly them in they become so now
they're in yeah they're entirely
dependent on you and because you're
controlling all of their wages and you
are demonstrating that you are lying to
them about what kind of wages they have
you also put them in a debt trap you're
like oh well
here is how much the webcam is and and
all this other [ __ ] is that I'm paying
for so you have to like basically pay me
back for the room and board the lodging
services this was all uncovered in the
original press release from the
investigation and it's pretty basic
stuff pretty common stuff like one you
coerce them uh originally not to to do
sex work but specifically as like a
girlfriend right to move there you you
then you move and you separate them from
their friends and family and they're
entirely dependent on you in certain
instances he even branded them with
tattoos
um that was another thing like he
literally did the exact same thing that
Nexium and the sex cult did as well
Nexium also branded their their members
uh as well like the the victims and
um and you you break them down and make
them entirely dependent on you while
simultaneously saying like I am your I'm
your meal ticket you don't know anything
you're in a new country I am your I'm
your shelter I'm your food I'm your meal
ticket your entire life belongs to me so
now shut the [ __ ] up and do my bidding
and his bidding happens to be webcamming
even if it wasn't webcaming it would
still be like illegal also he he even if
it wasn't sex work it would still be
also he's violent you've seen the video
of him beating the [ __ ] out of that
woman right he tells people that was
like role play
yeah I've seen it but I feel like didn't
I see the Same Girl come out and say
like oh this wasn't no there were
multiples no no there was one girl there
so I think he's like half into BDSM as
well uh I I originally talked about that
as well but
um the one of the victims uh said I'm
not a victim this is BDSM like I'm into
it right but there were others who uh
never came out in a similar uh in a
similar light there were multiple
different people that he had uh beaten
on camera that I I want to make a point
because like
I just want to talk to kind of what you
believe or what you're saying because
we're saying okay we have to prove that
there was no consent right that's how we
that's how we end this conversation so
so do you want so coercion right do you
think that coercion if you coerce
someone to come work for you is that the
same as consent do you think
I mean obviously coercion is not the
same as consent two different complete
things can you consent under coercion
like like can you actually consent to a
situation that you're being misled about
you know what I mean because you're
agreeing to one thing but it's entirely
a different thing like Andrew Tate in
some of these reports he these girls he
was saying come over let's get married I
want to be with you then they'd get
there and he'd get them into Cam work
and [ __ ] forget about him and you
know what I mean like he never he never
had the intention of being in a
relationship with them that's the lover
boy thing so can you consent to
something uh that you don't unders that
you're being misled about
it's you know it's this is obviously if
you're being if you're being coerced
into something you can't just consent
I've been in situations where I've had
to consent to things that I knew I was
being coerced in but like there were
other things that were forcing me to
have to consent to them because of
timing or because like for example I
mean I can't get in too much detail
because this would be put me in legal
trouble with like other [ __ ] but
um yeah I've been in situations where I
had to consent
even though there was coercion because I
also needed it to work out the way that
I needed it to work out so yeah there
can be other components like you don't
you're there could be other components
where like you're not giving
enthusiastic consent so ultimately what
ends up uh being an important piece of
this puzzle is like having enough
victims come out and offer personal
testimony
um there will always be like in the
Nexium sex cult situation people who
still say no he did not groom me I
wanted to do this I love him and you
know I got branded by him and it's it's
a shot it's a show of loyalty now that
literally Still Remains for Keith
Rainier these people went to the the
Brooklyn or I don't know where he's
actually being held but like they went
to his prison and they they have been
still actively they've been actively
defending some of the victims that were
groomed into being in a sex call still
actively defend Keith Rainier
today as well
yeah he's just this is just another I'm
just using a parallel here of like
grooming sexual abuse and like having a
sex call because it's like Epstein's the
best because it's so similar to what
they're doing it really is yeah but but
like I guess so not all coercion is
illegal let's go back to that right
because we all coerce people in our
course in our lives right persuasion
persuasion yeah I mean you could call it
persuasion right and that happens to all
of us it's not always illegal
but just imagine
you meet the girl of your dreams
she's Rich she's awesome she loves you
she wants to marry you and she's already
not buying it I'm already not buying it
I'm with you okay it's a little
different for a guy it's a little
different maybe maybe it's a little
different but just just uh just play
just be with me here for a second and in
your imagination would you want to
imagine you're a petite hot little 20
year old because I can do it that way if
that's better
okay you be yourself you be Bradley you
be Bradley
okay so there's this soup the girl your
dreams she says
Also let's pretend you have no prospects
you're like young you don't have a job
you're kind of lost you don't have a lot
going on
and so this girl she goes
I've got a super exciting life I've got
all this money I'm in love with you
actually I want to marry you
come to Romania and be with you I can't
even take you serious because it doesn't
even
have bro you'd think that wait
are you making fun of the situation I've
created or do you think this doesn't
happen in real life for men I mean like
I can never because I'm from my
perspective I can never imagine my like
my 100 beautiful this is exactly what I
want be rich and having all this [ __ ]
and then them coming to me and me having
nothing and then being like I want to
marry you I just never yeah so let's
pretend you're the hot 20 year old uh
so you got nice so put yourself in the
plate you got nice curves fat titties
huge ass bro
I mean it doesn't even have to be all
that you're you're 20 something years
old and you have no prospects in your
life okay and someone tells you they're
going to change your life they're
someone tells you they love you you fall
in love with them and then they
basically tell you that like uh you know
if you fly out here and live with me
I'll put you in a nice house I'll put
you in a [ __ ] Mansion I'll serve you
the best caviar the best food I'll give
you all the anabolic steroids you need
enjoy making him imagine he has a
beautiful lips I'm saying like because
that's like it's gonna take a very clean
straight I'm not sure no I'm putting him
in the spot
I'm gonna be honest I'm the kind of
person if someone told me that I'd be
like [ __ ] I'm not buying it bro you
can't you I'm not buying especially if
you're especially if you're vulnerable
though like and you don't have any
prospects and you trust this person
fully wait hold on I just wanted to yes
but once I just have one follow-up so
you're saying you can't imagine a
situation where a girl
is coerced by someone like Andrew Tate
to move there under close pretense I
can't imagine being a girl knowing what
I know I can't imagine putting myself in
that situation and believing that to be
true even when I was younger let me tell
you guys the story I was I was in my
early 20s and I was broke as [ __ ] I
lived in my car I lived in my car I got
offered eight thousand dollars to [ __ ]
students wife in Beverly Hills I didn't
do it because I was like this is a this
is a weird situation I don't want to be
involved I needed the money I had no
money I lived in my car and I didn't do
it because I was like this didn't feel
right what I'm saying is no matter what
my mind would never have worked that way
where I go oh I'm just going to get into
the situation yeah I know but I'm asking
you to use your imagination for a minute
but but a lot of these well by the way
part of the reason why you didn't want
to do that no you wouldn't fall hold on
this is a great no no this is a great
analogy this is actually awesome so part
of that was because you thought it was
weird right part of that is because you
thought it was unethical but there was
also a there was also a security issue
there right like you felt a little
vulnerable because like you don't know
what the [ __ ] this guy's going to do he
might like chop you up drug you right
well I've been in a weird situ I've been
in weird situations like that as well
where like uh I it this is important
we're big dudes we normally don't ever
have to think about like uh or or ever
consider like what women have to think
about 24 7 right but did you feel uh
like your physical safety might be
compromised in a similar situation
because like you don't know the
environment
well yeah I mean I could also know like
I don't know what's going on but it's
exactly exactly I've been in not like an
identical situation but I've been in a
similar situation before where that
actually helped me completely visualize
like the physical harm element that
women go through all the time on dates
and stuff so now how do you eliminate
that how do you eliminate that physical
uh harm component
you eliminate that by
spending enough time so that you trust
this person fully because if this wasn't
a random person but someone like that
you trust fully and it wasn't like a sex
act like that immediately but instead
something lighter and like a friend of
yours basically saying like I'm Gonna
Change Your Life I'm gonna [ __ ] you
know a girl that you're in love with
saying we're gonna change your life
we're gonna make it so much better and
it wasn't like [ __ ] some dude's wife
but instead like you know first you're
gonna show your titties on camera First
You're Gonna first you're gonna like
show your your muscles on camera and
then they slowly but surely like feed
you more and more stuff to do over the
process of like a month as you are like
completely alienated from your friends
and family and you're now living in this
new area where you have no
you you have you know your access to
shelter and everything else is directly
linked to this one person that you trust
fully you're not even going to think
about it even if they like take your
they can take your passport away and say
hey this is for your own safety you know
you might lose it by the way which uh
again according to the investigation
that was uh he was taking you know a
part of that
um
what I'm trying to say is like uh even
if you as a big intimidating guy uh have
a hard time understanding that I feel
like
if someone in when you were when you
were financially in a vulnerable
situation if someone had like come to
you under false pretenses and made you
fall in love with them and then
basically started like pushing your
boundaries and easing you into it you
probably would have been able to do
something maybe not like be the bull in
a cuck in a cuckolding situation but
like you know easily find yourself doing
like
sexual acts on webcams or whatever you
know what I mean slowly but surely we're
just trying to explain how like coercion
can be
I mean it is illegal right like how
that's human trafficky because it's hard
to say because you're we're you guys are
looking for something that's like she
said no and he lost any handcuffed her
and locked her to the pipe you know the
radiator right like that that's what you
want that's what you want to say okay
this guy's a human trafficker but it's
actually it's more how that worked yeah
it's never how that works I mean that is
how that works in some instances but
like the way more common method is
literally this where you like slowly but
surely feed these people lies can you
tell them you're in love with them and
then when they're like completely
trapped in your uh in your scheme that
you've like concocted at that point it
doesn't even matter and if they ever if
they ever step out of line you can even
you know give them physical threats uh
you know implied threats physical
coercion
or even in certain instances beat them
as and especially if you're like into
BDSM quote unquote and have like shown
that you have the capacity to beat some
of these women then you know you kind of
trap them in that situation where they
just don't want to they love you they're
in an abusive relationship with you
they don't want to they don't want to
offend you they don't want to upset you
you're their entire world and you're
betraying that trust by forcing them
into doing things that
um they may have wanted to do originally
but they have no other option now they
don't even have the option
I guess that's that that's uh it's a
little bit nuanced but what Hassan is
describing is actually illegal it's
coercion and it's that is actually human
trafficking that's the Loverboy thing
that resonated with you I mean that's
kind of a nuanced explanation
so you guys think
I
do
like 100
um I mean I don't know if he's 100
[ __ ] but he has openly talked about
his methods he always stops short every
single video I've seen of him talk about
his process of like how to get girls to
do webcam stuff he always stops short of
like openly stating how to keep your
[ __ ] in line you know what I mean he
he'll be he'll I've heard him say
numerous times you know the methods you
know what to do but like I won't be
saying them here like he'll always say
[ __ ] like that but
if you are being physically abusive if
you are being if you are intimidating
people like this and and you know some
of the the women that you you cast this
wide net on are gonna inevitably come
out in an investigation like this and
and validate those claims
those claims that you have uh made
freely okay let's I think listen
and then the other component is the rape
one like the sexual assault and and rape
let me come from a different angle up
Brad and by the way this is a good
conversation you know I mean don't feel
bad that you can express yourself and
feel how you want you know this is a
judgment-free Zone and uh
what like Planet Fitness
like Planet Fitness those [ __ ]
wait what because Planet Fitness is a
judgment-free Zone we don't let we don't
let fatties in the zoo
[Laughter]
the zoo is not a lunk free zone the Zune
is a the zoo is a lunk only Zone what's
a lunk isn't that what they say at
Planet Fitness a lunk that's a lot oh
they have a lunk alarm yeah yeah when
you drop weights I mean if you're
[ __ ] deadlifting four plays you're
gonna [ __ ] make some noise alarm yeah
they get mad at you if you if you drop
you allow lunking at your gym Bradley it
yes if we're considering deadlifting
monkey then yeah for sure you can lunk
over there bro that is a zoo that's why
I wanna yeah all right Bradley there's
one other thing I want to show you and
and you know I'm sorry it probably feels
like um
that we're barraging you right it's fine
so I'm gonna I gotta try to put it in
like simpler
more direct way so you know why he was
going back you know he was kicked off
Big Brother back in the day you know
about all that
I know that he was I know that he was on
it I didn't know I don't know the
details around him I don't know so he
was on Big Brother and he was actually
popular there uh people were liking him
because obviously for obvious reasons
right he's crazy he's got a big
personality he's funny
yeah
now he mysteriously left the show
and nobody knew why
this is all a matter of fact Vice
reported they gotten they got a hold of
the producers and the producers
confirmed that the reason they booted
him is because there was an
investigation ongoing in the UK for him
committing rape okay he what he wasn't
charged for it but this is what happened
okay
now now so so now I'm going forward the
girl who
um went to the police and said this guy
raped me
uh sent these voice messages to Vice so
I just want to play The Voice mess the
voice notes that Andrew Tate was sending
her and that she turned on hold on a
second yeah go ahead go ahead are these
the voice notes I've listened
I all I want to say is I think I might
have heard this [ __ ] and I'm gonna be
honest this sounds like some AI [ __ ]
it does the first the first few seconds
does sound weird but like it doesn't
matter it's it corresponds to like
actual investigations that were
conducted in the UK I mean they they got
yeah this is real they got it but that's
a girl that's just how different mics
make you sound different that's it and
and it's not just that but it's it
corroborates eyewitness testimony of
multiple people in the UK at the time
there was an official investigation that
they dropped and I will give you details
on that but here you you listen to this
then right I know what you mean I've
seen [ __ ] Elon Musk talk about
something he didn't talk about with some
AI technology no this isn't first of all
it's not AI because there's literally
actual human beings accompanying the the
you know the WhatsApp conversations let
me just say this the girl yeah the girl
who sent this device
send it to the police the police report
did happen the investigation did happen
so that it does sound a little funny
right it does sound a little bit like uh
uh at first AI generated at first it
sounds like right but that's also like
Mike difference is also like 2015 phone
mic WhatsApp and I think all of it is
that they're edited really close
together so it sounds a little unnatural
but what's important is that it's
corroborated by the police by the Girl
by The Big Brother so all this stuff did
happen right and this is what the girl
sent Vice news okay does that make sense
yes yes it does it does listen I'm not
trying to sit here and just defend this
guy and tell you the same time though
like police like all these people like I
just feel like at the same time like all
this like he's I don't know how to say
this I know you're not defending him I'm
just seeing if I can break through
that's all did you know no it's not the
Matrix because uh here's the here's the
other part of this that like I think
should be mentioned more frequently
in the UK
in England and in Wales there was an
internal review that was conducted about
police mishandling sexual assault cases
what happened to this girl uh is one of
those instances there's empirical
evidence for this they botched thousands
of cases and refused to prosecute them
including cases where like cops
themselves were in uh doing uh sexual
abuse personally this is actually a big
a big piece of the puzzle here which is
ironic because Andrew Tate was like oh
I'm going to Romania because in the UK
you can get into trouble for you know
assaulting someone or it's just that he
said she said situation and it's [ __ ]
up but like the reason why they dropped
the ball on this case
is because they dropped the ball on
thousands of instances of sexual assault
and they always ended up saying well it
seems like you wanted it it seems like
you were asking for it like that was
straight up the official response uh in
in you know it's a big Scandal you can
read about it but I I want to talk to
like basically something that so so you
sorry you were making a point and then
we keep going off on on tangents but I
want to hear your opinion wait I want to
hear this okay okay all right so so yeah
here it is
but now hundreds of cops are about to
get fired person because the more you
didn't like it the more I enjoyed it I
[ __ ] loved how much you hated it
turned me on
why am I like that
why I am one of the most dangerous men
on this planet sometimes you forget
exactly how lucky you were to get [ __ ]
by me would you rather me pin you down
and make you do things you didn't like
or would you rather [ __ ]
you didn't like the I was thinking I can
do whatever I want to
that's what it is I'm the smartest
person on this [ __ ] planet Are you
seriously so offended I strangled you a
little bit you didn't [ __ ] pass out
chill the [ __ ] out Jesus Christ I
thought you were cool what's wrong with
you
so I mean am I a bad person it's
interesting that this girl says she was
hard worded and went to the police
right
you're saying this girl this girl
there's some girl attached to the other
side of this yeah that got this like
look at my WhatsApp messages or some
[ __ ] she sent it to the police and to
Vice news she originally she went to the
police first in like a couple years
prior right uh after being in a
relationship with this person all right
and obviously rape and domestic abuse
does not happen in the way that like
people presented in movies where it's
like a random stranger that happens as
well but the most common instance of
rape and domestic abuse is like within
close Partners in a relationship family
members things like that now for that
reason they originally didn't do
anything with it but in 2015 another
victim came out so a second police
investigation was conducted into the
matter so they brought her back the
original uh victim they brought her back
in and they said would you testify and
she said yes of course I would so she
testified she gave all the WhatsApp
messages she gave of all the the audio
recordings from WhatsApp to the police
the police saw all of this and the other
uh testimony of the other uh uh victim
and ended up dropping the case the
prosecutor decided not to to follow
through with this investigation because
as they had done as they had done
thousands of times over so much so that
an investigation recently was conducted
into police mishandling sexual abuse
cases in the UK and now hundreds of
English police officers are facing
dismissal over sexual and domestic abuse
offenses because they just never
prosecuted it it was a systemic problem
but in the UK the point I think is that
you're looking for is that this is a
real voice note I don't know if you have
enough information to believe that but
it is corroborated by Vice news and the
police and Big Brother producers the
reason why I'm mentioning the other side
of this with like police dropping the
ball on this and the evidence for that
is because a lot of people look at this
and go how the [ __ ] if they had this
much evidence they didn't prosecute it I
agree that's like important that's what
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to a lot
of people I've talked to it I agree and
but like so they have too much plausible
deniability the tater tots so I want to
nail I want to just focus on one the
minutiae here a little bit or it's not
really minutia it's the meat of the
thing so do you do you have reservations
about this Voit nose if this vote votes
that if this voice note is real let's
assume what does it say to you assuming
it's real I can't assume that it's real
just makes them [ __ ] up about Assumption
of realness or not I mean he said he
sent me a voice note before what's
happened he didn't
put it on what it sounds like yeah but
that's from again remember this is from
2015. first of all here's one thing I
can tell you artifacting artifact thing
always happens no no I do believe in the
mate no no no no artifacting always
happens but here I'll explain it in the
easiest way possible please Ethan let me
explain it does it's no because anything
because I look the reality is if this
voice note
if this voice note was fake AI
technology in 2015 was not capable of
deep faking voices to the degree that
they are now you're thinking with your
brain in 2023. Brad thinks it was made
recently it's not yeah Brad thinks it
was made recently I know but there is
there is metadata in voices in the
metadata I know but like Brad but even
if Brad saw the metadata he would not
understand it I wouldn't even understand
Brad needs to see the WhatsApp messages
right on the phone somebody's scrolling
like you want to see like that shit's
good point the point is the point is
Sonia never gonna have that yeah the the
level of the level of evidence that you
need in a lot of these instances you're
never going to get you're not going to
get access to all the [ __ ]
information you didn't have that for
Jeffrey Epstein but you believe it why
because you understand that like one you
understand human motivation and two you
understand that like
uh institutions that go through this
stuff will oftentimes do their due
diligence right and I believe that the
British police did their due diligence
to know that this was valid but that's
not the reason why they dropped the case
they didn't say they dropped this case
because the voice notes were fake
because they would have said that they
dropped the kids if the voice note was
fake why wouldn't they just come out and
say well the voice note is fake and
that's why we dropped the case they
didn't say that though they said they're
dropping the case because they did not
think that they they uh they did not
think that they could set up good enough
accept it you're like in denial right
Brad if it was a deep fake the British
police would have said it's a deep fake
and that's why we dropped it no if they
wouldn't say [ __ ] it was me no it was
made recently and sent the vice to
deceive people like me and you the Sheep
In The Matrix agents to believe it's
fake right Brad
I don't know yeah yeah and how can we
ever know no I'm I'm how can we ever
know anything I'm literally I'm giving
I'm giving Bradley the benefit of that
here
why trying to describe to him why it
doesn't make sense no no no I'm trying
Brad how do you how do we know anything
like it's just at the end of the day
Hassan answer that
you know you're you're such a [ __ ] I
mean at the end of the day right I mean
I'm riding with you now Brad [ __ ] it
I gotta see those texts bro I gotta you
know what I gotta see a video of Andrew
filming himself speaking into a phone
and even then Bradley the technology is
pretty [ __ ] crazy these days like
that could be fake too to be honest okay
we have to we have to we have to trust
that like
we have the trust that for example you
know things that we read have to be
valid there are uh numerous there are
numerous safeguards uh when you read
like a New York Times article even
though they do have the capacity to
[ __ ] uh print something that's untrue
they believe that like I don't like the
New York Times I'm not a big fan of
major media but there's a there is a
method that like they go through when
they're investigating certain things and
if you didn't believe that then like
everything you believe you have to see
with your own you're missing the point
bro how do you even know that letters
are real how do you even know the
newspaper you're holding is real I'm not
gonna lie to you like I really don't
believe any of this media there it is
bro thank you Bradley I'm with Bradley
I'm taking his time if I'm just being
honest like I know they're they're I'm
not saying nothing is real nothing is
true yeah but based on my experience
it's not even about this taste [ __ ] just
like actually I'm curious I talk about
media literacy all the time this is a
fundamental problem okay a lot of people
under understandably do not trust
mainstream media which is adequate I
don't trust mainstream media either what
you need to understand is what are their
biases
you have to for example state news like
Al Jazeera or even the BBC they do a
pretty good job of covering other
countries news like when they're
covering America they're oftentimes more
objective when covering America but I
will never trust Al Jazeera when they're
covering Qatar because it's the [ __ ]
State broadcaster and they're always
going to lie about their own State okay
so you have to pinpoint what their
biases might be do they all and why they
cover and why they covered right Brad I
mean I don't know yeah yeah we don't
believe anything they're not buyers
against the entertainment is a low-level
criminal like they don't give a [ __ ] no
they hate him because he's because he's
speaking of men right Brad
a part of it I think that's part of it I
don't know about all of it yeah they
don't like him because he's speaking in
mid as men Hassan no that's that's just
crazy there's so many people that speak
to men that are just as big pieces of
[ __ ] as Andrew Tate is but they're not
[ __ ] like if that was the case Steven
Crowder would be getting false charges
for rape and sexual assault and sex
trafficking Ben Shapiro will be getting
that there are plenty of Jordan Peterson
is more dangerous than them right Brad
no he's not he doesn't even let Brad
answer
I don't think about necessarily more and
more more dangerous than that I just
think it's more like he's the most
popular thing to talk about period right
I just think there is some biases around
the fact that like you can look at any
of the content and all the content the
discusses tape just gets more views more
everything like there is something
relevant to that that all new sources
understand and know just like YouTubers
understand to know and twitch streamers
understand you know yeah and it's
current and there's we're all making
money from that you are I am news yes
covering Jeffrey Epstein's trial is
making me money and therefore what are
my biases against Jeffrey Epstein you
know listen to what I'm saying you can
look at your views the amount you
covered Jeffrey Epstein the mountain you
cover Andrew Ted I guarantee you add
those views up say double triples that's
not true when when when Jeffrey Epstein
was relevant before he was you know
suicide I'm gonna stop you right there
you just nailed it when Jeffrey Epstein
was relevant you were making more money
off of Jeffrey Epstein talking about him
now that he's not his relevant now that
he's dead I mean shut the [ __ ] up he's
dead
no hold on Hassan what after he died
why'd you stop talking about him bro I
mean I still do talk about that oh it's
not I'm not talking about him
specifically it's about talking all
about why are you not talking about the
People The Client List Right Brad
that's a yeah it's a piece that's a
that's a piece of it Hassan what about
the clients I'm on your side bro
it's too big it's too much it's too big
you talking about Andrew because you
can't people say that first of all the
clients on two things at the same time
but I'm not even talking about that I'm
talking about like but this is not an
argument okay of course you're gonna
talk about ongoing injustices if there
is an ongoing Injustice happening okay
if Andrew Tate has an active
investigation being conducted then of
course I'm going to talk about that
instead of the guy who has been dead now
for many [ __ ] years his Lane's alive
well I've talked about like jizz Lane as
well it's not even about that it's about
the fact that there is for sure a list
of people that they know damn well
exactly they are and no one talks about
it so I know you're saying it's not as
current it's not as relevant the guy's
dead regardless of that fact there's
still a list of people who did the same
[ __ ] yeah bro they gave into the same
type of thing that we're talking about
they did the same [ __ ] thing as
Andrew Tate and they're walking free
aren't they I know but that's not a
defense foreign
listen I'm not defending what Andrew
take did or did not do I'm not defending
this I'm defending the fact that there
are still a bunch of scumbag
[ __ ] who are walking around
just fine as day and we're not making
any content about them because we're not
making money no one gives a [ __ ] because
everyone's dead at it they stop talking
about it but that still exists that
truth for all those people who have kids
okay they can't talk about [ __ ] Bradley
Bradley this doesn't make any sense and
here's why okay if someone goes out and
murders someone okay if someone goes out
and murders another human being and
there's an active investigation being
conducted into that murder but the
person happens to be [ __ ] famous so
everyone is covering it uh that famous
person can't turn around and go well
other people are murdering other people
why the [ __ ] are you talking about my
murder case
at all try listening we're talking about
two separate things have all the
he's saying Bradley's saying keep the
same energy right Brad I'm saying yeah
okay so what about someone who does keep
the same energy because I do keep the
same energy you know what I mean I I do
I keep the same energy for for all of
these according to Brad and Brad I think
I'm gonna represent you well here he
says if you add up the time from the G
Lane [ __ ] and you add up the Tate time
the energy ain't the same right Brad no
it's not the energy the same because the
views aren't the same brother it's
energy the science energy might be
exactly the same because I don't think
Hassan is the kind of person that just
goes well I just want to hit an
entertain because I just want to hate it
I know what I'm saying I'm just talking
about the relevancy of the [ __ ] views
and then it leads us as content creators
to make more content towards it which I
understand is why we're having this
conversation today I know but that
doesn't change but but you're not but
we're not talking now about the details
of the investigation and whether or not
Andrew Tate did it or not we're just
simply having a we're just simply having
a conversation about like of course
someone who is more famous or more
culturally relevant than jizz Lane
Maxwell getting more clicks and more
eyeballs yes if it came out tomorrow
that Brad Pitt was [ __ ] sex
trafficking people then that would be
well infinitely more uh relevant than
Andrew Tate even sex trafficking people
I'm not saying he did I'm saying like oh
yeah he's a very famous included Brad
Pitt so of course everyone would [ __ ]
talk about it like that but that is
completely that is materially irrelevant
to the facts of the matter and I think a
lot of people without realizing get into
like a different collection mechanism a
deflection mode to like bring this up is
in an effort to like find hypocrisy
somewhere but there is no hypocrisy
there yes if famous people commit crimes
more people talk about it because they
are famous that doesn't change the
reality of whether a crime was committed
or not and that is
I'm just saying I wish that we were able
to go towards that not just making
content about it but like there's still
clearly a whole group of people who did
a ton of dirt that they're just walking
around I agree with you
Bradley let me ask you something
what at what point
will you believe something you see or
hear we're talking about news or we're
talking about Andrew Tate's voice memos
how can at what point are you like this
is real
what do you need
to be honest man like that's that's why
this shit's so weird like you can't yeah
I think because I have so much mistrust
in media in general and I have so much
mistrust and even even in like the
internet and the way people make content
on social media and how like I've been
lied about countless times on the
internet to my dismay to someone else's
benefit for years so it's easier for me
to be able to like I'm not sitting here
trying to defend someone at all but I
can put myself in a position where I've
been attacked multiple times for someone
else's benefit for someone else's views
for someone else's money so it's hard
for me to believe really anything like
and that's the tough part because I'm
not a police officer I'm not doing an
investigation I'm not talking to these
women I'm not in it so I can't make a
real assessment to it I will tell you
though from my personal experience I've
dealt with so much personal [ __ ] in
regards to people saying things about me
that just 100 are true and I just had to
live with it I had to deal with it I had
to deal with the shitty comments I had
to deal with the hate messages I had to
deal with nonsense I deal with people
trying to tear me down turn my
businesses down my
there's a difference between like people
[ __ ] on Andrew Tate for like
misogyny or whatever versus like actual
criminal actions because there are
multiple different avenues like
institutions that are also now involved
you have on the one hand institutions
and organizations in the UK that uh you
know failed to investigate him properly
right let me stop you I'm not saying
you're you're wrong I know everything
you're saying I know what you're about
to say it's true I was just sharing my
opinion why if I'm answering this
question what do I need to see so it
seems like you'll never nothing can ever
convince you I have really I'm gonna
tell you I think when the investigation
concludes uh and and if the
investigation shows like if he's
convicted will that convince you
probably yeah yeah okay let me ask you
I'm trying to focus on something else
real fast
in the video which we all agree is real
he says he lies to the girls he takes 70
and gives them 30. he tells them he
splits it he lies to them he says he's
paying taxes he's not and so we all
agree that he's doing that right
he said he's doing that yeah he's doing
that he's doing that that's frog okay so
that's fraud and it's theft right so
he's a criminal already
okay okay so this is good
so imagine a guy who's willing to do a
crime and you've seen the way he talks
about the women with such disdain right
like he doesn't [ __ ] have any respect
or care for them at all I mean how could
you if you're like yo here's fake tax
fraud so I can steal money from you I
mean so so so again is that someone who
respects the women he works with or is
that someone who sees them as more of a
[ __ ]
crypto farming human crypto Farms
is [ __ ] obviously yeah it's [ __ ] and
he's and he's committing a crime right
he's stealing from them
by his own admission by his own words I
mean he did say that yeah yeah so he's
so he's stealing from the girls we know
that for sure
which I'm not looking at that I'm like
that's why I can't
yep he said that and so that one we
can't even debate he's stealing from him
he's just stealing and he's lying to
them with fake tax forms that's like
super high level fraud you can't fill
out fake tax forms right like that's
super illegal
yeah I mean that's yeah I would go to
jail for that yeah yeah yeah big time
but also imagine how much you'd have to
hate or not respect the other person on
the side of that
yeah I'm assuming so yeah just don't
treat you don't think that they're fully
fledged human beings if you're [ __ ]
them over like that
so so like is it so when you start there
this is what he said he goes yo I'm
stealing from them I'm talking about it
openly these people have fun are nothing
to me except a [ __ ] ATM machine
so I mean from there it's not that much
of a leap right to think about he's
coerced them to come there and work for
him because he's basically said they're
human ATM machines to him
I hear your point yeah here yeah okay
okay good
nice
but he's committed he's the thing is we
can all agree he's stealing from them
yeah yeah
does that mean the standards of of sex
trafficking is the question for for
Bradley and I believe that uh do given
the legal definition of like the lover
boy method and grooming and coercing
women into sex trafficking especially
when the investigation is concluded and
it shows like witness testimony about
physical coercion physical intimidation
paired up with all of the things that he
has said about like beating women paired
up with like videos of him actually
beating women I think it's a pretty
pretty open and shut case having said
that though just like in the UK I do not
believe like when we talk about the
Matrix like I don't think the Matrix is
uh is is as against Andrew Tate as he
claims it is if anything The Matrix is
shown time and time again if you think
of like cultural hegemony the world that
we live in uh time and time again has
shown that it doesn't usually side with
women it usually usually sides with
perpetrators it usually sides with
people in power so
um I I don't even know I don't even know
what will happen in the Romanian court
system let me throw a hypothetical to
you you just started with the nelk
podcast right and congratulations that's
awesome you're a great presence there
everybody loves that you're there let's
say you make this deal with Kyle and he
goes yo we're gonna go 50 50 on this
you're like awesome 50 50.
um
and then you find out a few years later
he was actually keeping 70 percent
giving you 30 just straight up lying to
you and keeping [ __ ] 20 that whole
time bro imagine how little respect he'd
have for you just to [ __ ] steal 20
from you like that for years and then
you go and then you go oh maybe you find
out about it you so this seems light bro
like where's the other
where's the other 20.
well it's not that different
he goes he goes oh I'm I paid taxes with
it you know what's crazy about that is
that the girls still have to pay the
taxes on the 30 yeah so
so like the the level to which he's
[ __ ] them over I mean if we're going
that theoretical situation yeah yeah
they're not going to sue but they're not
going to sue him you understand that
right
yeah no they're not going to sue Andrew
because he kind of they're fully
dependent they live in his compound it's
like he said remember his words was like
I feed you I pay for all this [ __ ] I
know what it is I've got the
infrastructure I've got the house he
said like he is
he's like yo you live here you're in my
world you know what I mean like he said
that basically when he was like I do
this I do this I do this I do this just
shut up and do the cam work
so they're not gonna they're not gonna
sue him I mean no [ __ ] shot
right
I mean I guess I don't know yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's it's easy to suggest
that so again we're painting a picture
here where he's stealing money
from them he's using them and they're in
a position where they're not really
gonna have the power to do anything
about it
right because with you you got it you're
a guy you're an influencer you can walk
away you can sue him you can make a
video These Girls can't really do it and
if you're a moldovan like 18 year old
who now lives in [ __ ] Romania and
you're scared of him too because he's a
big guy you're in love with him and then
you're like kind of scared of him
because you're an abusive like a
relationship with him uh alongside like
18 other girls if he's also claimed yeah
you don't have any [ __ ] legal
recourse you're not even thinking about
the legal recourse like it's not out of
the question because you're you're
thinking about survival you don't even
live there bro like you know I mean you
don't even speak Romanian who are you
gonna who gonna talk to about it and
then imagine this the guy there he's a
[ __ ] kickboxer and he's into BDSM
he's a little [ __ ] crazy in bed and
maybe you like it a little bit because
he [ __ ] slaps you up and [ __ ] but
then all of a sudden you're like this
guy's a little crazy he's a kickboxer
he's a hot head what's he gonna do to me
if I try to sue him or go to the police
what do you think you think a girl is
going to just be and she [ __ ] lives
in Romania she came here from some like
where did you say Moldova she came here
from Moldova and she's living in Romania
she didn't even speak the language right
and on top of that so what's she gonna
do on the internet that this dude has
Legions of [ __ ] fans that like go
absolute ape [ __ ] over anything he does
you think that this is like a powerful
figure
both in your life and in general because
he is like people will if you come out
against a a a very famous person like
this like yeah you know people are gonna
[ __ ] destroy you so does that kind of
make sense like a in this picture we're
painting where this girl who he's
stealing money from does it make kind of
make sense right where she's not gonna
be able to do anything in fact she'd
probably you can admit scared of him a
little bit
I mean in the picture opinion absolutely
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not
human trafficking that's human
trafficking it's not that big of a
restraint it is because that's kind of
what it is right I mean you know he's
not forcing them to stay
right but he's created a situation where
they pretty much
have no choice
and they're scared of him
and that's human trafficking foreign
[Music]
it's crazy right because he convinced
them to come over there because he
wanted to marry them he said they love
them they trust him and then all of a
sudden this is The Situation he's
stealing their money
and they can't do anything about it
they have no they're scared of him
we're also making money
they're making well he said himself he
goes if I if we make ten thousand
dollars then she gets um three thousand
dollars and by the way in some of the
reports and we don't need to speculate
because I like that this hypothetical
situation is pure but in some of the
reports they said that he was
withholding their money and not paying
them and stuff like that yeah
but but let's say yeah I mean yeah so so
let's say yeah they're making money
three thousand dollars let's say there's
a top earner there let's say she's
killing it bro she's bringing in tons of
cash right she's the she's like huge and
let's say they're making
let's say they're making a hundred
thousand dollars a month bro crushing it
so she's getting thirty thousand that's
a lot of money right so imagine she goes
to Andrew listen
I don't want to do this with you anymore
I'm gonna leave and do it on myself or
she gonna say I want to leave because I
made enough money and I don't want to do
this anymore what do you think Andrew's
gonna tell her
I'm assuming he's going to try to
convince her not to leave yeah and he's
scary and she's here from another
country she doesn't even speak the
language also he's stealing her money
let's say she found about that and she
says I want my money back
you know what is he gonna do
she he's a little scary he's a kickboxer
and he's into BDSM
and he has guns he has armed guards
there he has a ton of guns bro
no but this is all based on what he said
this is all based on the premise that we
agreed on is that he's stealing money
from them so if you stop if you start
from there and build up I'm just saying
everything all the other things to like
paint the picture
at the same time the theoretical
situation you're creating right now for
all you know maybe he said someone said
that to him maybe I want some more money
he goes okay bye how do you know the
benefit because he might have said that
to one or two people but if there are
enough people that he did not say that
to that's still illegal you know what I
mean like let's say you're again going
back to the murder analogy if you murder
one person you murder two people you
murder three people but then the fourth
person you let go that doesn't absolve
you of the three murders that you've
conducted
yeah of course not you know you're still
a murderer at that point but I think the
premise we've built here is very
plausible considering what we know for
sure which is that he's willing to steal
money from them and lie to them and that
he is a kickboxer he has a compound with
guards he is a kickboxer and we've seen
a video of him beating the [ __ ] out of a
woman maybe she liked it but either way
he's capable of slapping a woman in the
face really hard because we've seen it
on camera right he's comfortable doing
that in fact he likes it
yeah the thing that I never started is
that he did say on camera behind a
paywall saying that like I'm comfortable
with basically stealing from his people
he did say that so that's pretty
interesting right
that wasn't even like an admission he
was flexing that he was saying you
should do that as well he was teaching
that yeah he was educating others to do
the same thing that's Hustler University
bro that's what he thinks young men in
the world need to hear what do you think
about that that was the first iteration
I don't think that was Hustler's
University level I think that was before
when he was like teaching people how to
do like literally the lover boy method
ironically until he got called out and
deleted it from his [ __ ] website so
let me ask you this he is breaking
through to men do you think that video
we watched is something that's good for
men to see because that's kind of that's
that's his specialty bro that's his
background that's how he made money
that's the game
yeah I mean that that honestly you know
it's bad I'm telling people you're just
telling people to lie to people and to
take more money yeah
yeah it is
I think we found some common ground here
yeah it's undeniable that
can't make that up I wish I saw that
clip I've never seen
it and I just saw it on Monday right
it's it just kind of is making the
rounds now
um I just saw it too if I had it I would
have shown it to you earlier
but I feel like I feel like this is this
has been good actually I feel like this
has been good
yeah this is a productive conversation
yeah more people need to hear things
like this and you got to take the time
out and explain it to people I know
other people get like immediately mad
and go oh just end a conversation shut
it down shut it down but like no you a
lot of people do not comprehend that
like what Andrew Tate is doing on a
grander scheme is playing into the
Matrix the real Matrix which is
patriarchal constructs which of course
allow for the objectification of women
and also capitalism which allows for
coercive conditions in which you employ
people and you [ __ ] them over every boss
[ __ ] their employees over whoa I mean
to a certain degree
is what it is there's there are levels
of this where [ __ ] guys there are
levels of this where you know you can
there are levels in which you can do it
in a way where like your employees are
happy they're stable they love the
workplace they they love all of that
okay I mean I have I have uh
collaborators as well so
but that is the reason why people look
to normalize this kind of behavior or
that is the reason why people turn a
blind eye to this kind of behavior
because they just don't think about it
as like anything out of the ordinary but
when you pair it up together and you
like withhold passports and and you know
lie and withhold wages and openly admit
that you're lying about that sort of
thing then it becomes like extra illegal
to the degree where like the average
person should be able to comprehend it
see you're such a nice guy Brad you
can't even imagine lying to someone and
stealing like 20 of their money because
that's crazy I mean I've been [ __ ]
over so I'm sure you have bro yeah
that's and it's like you can't even
imagine it because you're a sweet guy
you're a genuine guy but imagine the
type of person it takes to be like I'm
gonna take steal 20 from her I'm gonna
lie to her and I'm even gonna print out
fake tax forms so that she shuts the
[ __ ] up like imagine the type of person
is that the same person that you met
with and who's like cool and awesome
Andrew Tate who you you know he things
you think he's an awesome guy and you
say that does that jive with the guy you
know
no no it doesn't
and is it possible that Andrew Tate and
this is a big leap so apologies if you
can't join me on this is a high level
functioning psychopath who
well is it that hard to believe he's
stealing money from them and lying to
them and printing out fake tax boards
and then making videos about it is it
how much does he benefit from being
friends with you in the milk boys ask
answer that and Aiden and Aiden Ross how
much money has he made for making
content with you guys because y'all are
like you guys by your own statement
you're 95 men y'all are the men's club
and that's cool it's a mutually
beneficial relationship because the
other side like there's a reason why
some people uh go to certain lengths to
defend Andrew Tate as well like because
Andrew Tate does bring relevancy
so that's the reason why the fresh and
fit podcasters were literally like dick
riding him so hard even though they were
not allowed to have conjugal visits with
Andrew Tate in Romania they were writing
underneath his [ __ ] they were running
under these tweet like we should bring
the boys over there right like should
the Freshman fit podcast go to Romania
it's like bro how [ __ ] desperate like
holy [ __ ] because
he said he's gonna go
huge mistake and obviously you know how
we feel about it I I want to I I can't
get through to that man I just that boy
it's it's so good for him and he sees
how much no I think it's beyond that I
think like I think he's been groomed I
think
I think uh that you know Andrew Tate is
a relatively charismatic figure
especially if you're like world view
aligns with his and he's like a funny
guy so I think that's part of the other
reason why like people
are ready to defend them because they
find him to be like funny and they find
him to be their friend also it's easy to
not look at the really
red flags it's easy to kind of look past
those okay I look at everything man
that's good that's why you're the man
that's why I like this conversation
so but let me ask you this because I I
want to finish this point
okay how much money do you think Andrew
Tate made from his association with nelk
with you and Aiden Ross like how many
Hustler University memberships did he
sell from that it's right a lot to be
honest I mean I don't know the reason
why I can't just say like that's all it
is because at the same time we also
realize like it's not like
we were like hey Andrew Tate no one
knows you let's make content together
now everyone knows you he did blow
himself up like like everyone's been
using him if I'm being honest everyone's
using oh he's the one that's being used
okay interesting no I there it's
mutually beneficial he's not the one
who's being used he there's a reason why
he would go on all these shows because
he doesn't have a steady flow of like
audience that he can tap into in the
same way that like like Aiden Roz has
loyal fans and hundreds of thousands of
people that tune into his stream every
day
that is very valuable to someone like
Andrew Tate who doesn't have his own
like personal media operation in the
same vein he had a he had a YouTube
channel Tate speech or whatever that
wasn't popping you know what I mean
until until like The Tick Tock stuff uh
blew up but even then he needed like
collaborations and you understand this
as a content creator like you have to
collaborate with other content creators
to continue growing your audience to
continue your material fresh uh to keep
your material fresh and and to have a a
steady flow of like new people coming in
and that is precisely what he did with
with Aiden Ross and everything else with
everyone else and and let me throw
another Point too
this is a man who we've all agreed by
his own words
is willing to steal from his girls and
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about them he's
steal from them and he'll Lie from them
so this is a guy who has some
Psychopathic Tendencies because it
that's not normal to be able to do that
right like that that's that seems
pathological to me to be that
comfortable stealing and lying to
someone about it right that's not I
don't know about psychological I don't
know about pathological order some
people that's not normal bro
I don't think it's normal no no I don't
think it's normal I think a lot of
people do it but I don't I don't think
it's like but the way he talked about it
and the way he's proud of it and he
wants to teach people how to do it it's
just not it to me that's not normal
behavior yeah when you don't believe
your victims are people and so right and
so this is the guy who is going to Buddy
up with Aiden Ross and with nelk because
they got that perfect audience and he's
going to be the biggest sweetheart to
you right like y'all are gonna hang out
for three hours after the show and he's
gonna he [ __ ] loves y'all and he's
and you know by the way Psychopaths
super charming and I'm not making a joke
that's one of the traits is that they're
extremely charming and extremely
manipulative and so he's going to turn
it on because guess what y'all are super
[ __ ] useful to him uh and all and and
guess what it's good for him too because
it's useful for you guys it's like
win-win but just like a course you're
gonna love his ass after three hours
because he's super charming and he's
super smart and he's super manipulative
and we know he's manipulative because
how he lied to his girls uh
[Music]
I'm just saying bro and something to
chew on something that you want no I
hear you yeah yeah
you're the man bro thanks for talking to
us
dude I apologize yeah my bad
[ __ ] he calling you wait who's
calling you
this is [ __ ] my videographers the
hell bro
no I know I gotta tell him to shut the
[ __ ] up right and give you my money or
what not I want to say thank you for
talking to us I know that we've we
barraged you a little bit but I'm happy
we had this conversation because I think
it's useful and I I really think it's
great that we're able to at least find
some common ground here which I think we
did
yeah no I appreciate it I appreciate you
guys have me on always I mean it's all
up no matter what you know so we can say
we can all agree Andrew Tate is a
criminal
well I mean [ __ ] yes I can say that for
sure he admitted to stealing money from
these people so he's a criminal
bye bye
okay okay so that's there it is
let's start there baby
okay listen Bradley you're the man go
out there lift some heavy [ __ ] Bro go
lift that no it's all good go lift the
heaviest [ __ ] [ __ ] in that Gym Bro
I appreciate you guys got to come train
one of these days we're gonna I'm down
100 you're the man bye dude love you
Brad besties forever
he's gonna lift the heaviest [ __ ] right
now dude
what do you think I think we got through
to him a little bit I think so too yeah
and I apologize for doing a little bit
of trolling I felt that it wasn't going
anywhere productive for a minute and I
just thought
I tried goofing around a little we do a
little trolling it's all good
yeah yeah
sorry to cut you off sometimes no no
it's fine
for everyone in the chat who don't
understand like why do you have to have
this conversation it's like well there
are a lot of dudes who have this opinion
whether you like it or not so I think
this is a very constructive conversation
to have when you it's almost like
when you have friends that have like
shitty opinions or whatever you don't
immediately dismiss them and you know
alienate them which will then further
push them aside and and most likely uh
could have them continue that kind of
bad behavior you treat them you know you
yeah try to pull them in and explain the
situation step by step and Bradley's a
great guy this is happening yeah there's
nothing in a public scale that is is
very constructive in my opinion I agree
I think it's awesome and the thing is
like yeah I mean listen we've all talked
about Andrew Tate so much but the
problem is is that there's like an iron
curtain that people like me and you
can't break through and so if we can
find a way to actually
breaking because this whole manosphere
red pill thing is really corrosive yeah
and we gotta I'm I really want to show
what a [ __ ] fraud it all is and
Brad's the man dude so I love Bradley
he's super strong which is awesome
is who is he stronger than you Hassan do
you think what yes okay because yeah I
don't know you left a lot yeah he's he's
literally 260 he's heavier than me with
like seven or not seven but like you
know eight to ten percent body fat he's
really tall he's it's he I'm taller than
him but I'm like I'm six four he's six
three
but it doesn't matter because like he is
just all muscle like I still have a lot
of fat
he's crazy he's insanely strong that's
awesome I respect that about him uh I do
I I legitimately do I know you know that
I just that that's a lot of [ __ ]
effort that you put into something the
man lives and breathes lifting Heaven
[ __ ] by the way have you seen liver
King's body since he stopped the roids
he's it's coming down a little bit no
really his pecs look normal now oh
that's sad still looks good now he looks
good
um he should have kept doing it nobody
likes a quitter liver King
what the [ __ ] is this
I think his lawyer said you gotta show
that you gotta try to not look that
different because we're gonna lose this
lawsuit for sure
here is Brian
is when he's off steroids my second
dinner with zero calories but that
doesn't mean the king is not gonna eat
dude he seems [ __ ] Haggard he looks
just look at him man he is he's he's
pretty [ __ ] tone man you can see I
have four different types of salt I got
some slab yeah show me a picture of him
recently I think from today okay check
this out this is this is crazy now of
course he's in insane shape right but
yeah that ain't the same
this kind of stuff is really hard to
measure on photos unfortunately because
like you know photo to photo you could
literally look
you can liter I mean it does seem like
he's he's uh losing some weight his
dress I mean his his chest muscles words
I never seen anything like that now they
look normal I mean they're like real
well his abs still look insane but uh
you know he still
I think the hardest component here is
that it's going to be it's going to be
hard to maintain his body fat percentage
this is before
this is after
it's gonna be hard to maintain his body
fat percentage uh and and muscle mass
for sure honestly you can you can almost
convict him on this photo alone
like he's like yo the liver did this
[ __ ] yeah he's a lot more full than that
one
here's here's liver King here's Brian
all right we did a good one today
we didn't get to talk about anything we
planned but that's the magic of the show
in it that's how it works sometimes
you gonna go live stream now yeah well
we're back baby leftovers back better
than ever
[Applause]
so much time looking into George Santos
last night and we didn't even get to it
but it's kind of Evergreen we could
probably just talk about it oh yeah
George Santo he healed more next week
there's gonna be like 11 New Lies the
[ __ ] docket any document anyway so
we're gonna find out he's not even human
he's he's something else you know what I
mean he'll lie about anything that you
can lie about
all right y'all thank you thank you
Hassan it's nice to see you it's nice to
have the show back I think we're uh
doing good things here and uh see y'all
tomorrow Anthony fantano's coming in
I'm gonna have them on on Saturday
that's all he's just gonna sit with you
like on the stream we'll do all that
we'll do the Pod I might work out with
him on Saturday morning too get those
[ __ ] beefy legs in action I want to
see those vegan gains dude he's he's
jacked he's got some thick thighs you
know thick thighs save lives
I respect that he's vegan that's pretty
dope yeah
all right Anthony he'll be here tomorrow
Hassan we love you
fans
we love you more we're back we're back
we're freaking back see y'all tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]